I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我今年50岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？大概有几件。我不想让全家人挤在同一个只有一间卧室和浴室的房间里。我不想。不。我不想我们所有人都挤在一起。我想要有自己的卧室，和孩子们分开，这就是我更喜欢爱彼迎（Airbnb）的原因。因为我们可以各自拥有空间，这会让整个假期变得更放松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者最近更有可能的是，我比其他人先睡。你知道我喜欢爱彼迎的什么吗？什么？零食。你知道我喜欢爱彼迎的什么吗？什么？零食。你有冰箱，有厨房。所以我不用一直叫客房服务，也不用支付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. What's in this McDonald's bag? The McValue Meal. For $5.79 plus tax, you can get your choice of junior chicken, McDouble, or chicken snack wrap,
我只会说，嘿，我们带了零食，都在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，下次旅行考虑一下爱彼迎吧。从传统酒店换到爱彼迎，你绝对不会后悔。这个麦当劳袋子里装的是什么？麦当劳超值套餐。只需5.79美元加税，你就可以选择小份鸡肉汉堡、双层吉士汉堡或鸡肉卷，
plus small fries and a small fountain drink. So pick up a McValue Meal today at participating McDonald's restaurants in Canada. Prices exclude delivery. Hello everyone, and welcome to our second drink of Office Olympics. I really love this episode so much. But my favorite stuff is the stuff in the condo with Michael and Dwight.
再加上小份薯条和小杯饮料。所以今天就去加拿大参与活动的麦当劳餐厅购买麦当劳超值套餐吧。价格不含外送费。大家好，欢迎收看我们《办公室奥运会》的第二杯饮品。我真的很喜欢这一集。但我最喜欢的是迈克尔和德怀特在公寓里的那些戏份。
I ended up rewatching this whole episode. And I think that I love that stuff because we weren't there. And so when I watch them, I think I'm really seeing them as an audience member. And those two are so funny. There's just something so fun about seeing Michael and Dwight out of the office to me. Just the way they interact with each other when they're out in the world is hilarious. Yes. I mean, it starts with them driving to the condo, and Dwight is like messing with Michael's
我最后把这一整集又重看了一遍。我想我喜欢那些戏份是因为我们当时不在场。所以当我看着他们时，我觉得自己真的像个观众。那两个人太搞笑了。对我来说，看到迈克尔和德怀特离开办公室，总有一些特别有趣的地方。他们身处外面的世界时那种互动方式简直太滑稽了。是的。我的意思是，从他们开车去公寓开始，德怀特就在摆弄迈克尔的
car. And when we did our breakdown of this episode people were quick to point out that I said this is the first time we see Michael's car but we actually saw it in Hot Girl. Well and you got mail about it. I did. And Jenna you know what I love is when we get to the condo well there's a scene we didn't talk about it much the first time. Let's hear it. Michael this is Bill he's the head of the condo association. Oh, hey, how are you? Nice to meet you, Bill.
车。当我们回顾这一集时，人们很快指出我说这是我们第一次看到迈克尔的车，但实际上我们在《辣妹》那一集就看到了。嗯，你还收到了关于这件事的邮件。是的。而且珍娜，你知道我喜欢什么吗？当我们到达公寓时，有一场戏我们第一次没怎么聊。我们来听听看。迈克尔，这是比尔，他是业主委员会的主席。哦，嘿，你好吗？很高兴见到你，比尔。
Bill, Mr. Bill. Oh, no. Mr. Bill. SNL. When they pull him apart, you would always get rolled over by something. Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you, too. This is smaller than your old place.
比尔，比尔先生。哦，不。比尔先生。《周六夜现场》。当他们把他拆开时，他总是会被什么东西碾过。很高兴见到你。也很高兴见到你。这比你以前的地方小。
Yes, well, I'm buying it and I'm not renting it. You would always get rolled over by something. Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you too. This is smaller than your old place. Yes, well, I'm buying it and I'm not renting it. So it's still an upgrade. He doesn't know anything about property ownership. Kind of an idiot. It's just so great. It's just so great. And I wanna give a guest star shout out
是的，嗯，我是买下来的，不是租的。他总是会被什么东西碾过。很高兴见到你。也很高兴见到你。这比你以前的地方小。是的，嗯，我是买下来的，不是租的。所以这仍然是一个升级。他对房产所有权一窍不通。简直是个白痴。这太棒了。这太棒了。我想给客串明星点个赞，
to John Harrington Bland as Bill, head of the condo association. He is so funny. The look on his face. John had a recurring role as a reporter on Spin City, which is probably why he was on Alison Jones's radar, since she also cast that show. But he's a really talented actor. He's been on so much, including recurring roles
就是饰演业主委员会主席比尔的约翰·哈林顿·布兰德。他太搞笑了。他脸上的表情。约翰曾在《政界小人物》中饰演一名常驻记者，这可能就是他进入艾莉森·琼斯视野的原因，因为她也为那部剧选角。但他确实是一位非常有才华的演员。他出演过很多作品，包括在
on Boardwalk Empire and The Loudest Voice. And now I've got a really fun catch from this episode that I can't believe we missed the first time around, Angela. What? At eight minutes and 35 seconds in the scene where Pam is hanging up her homemade banner in the kitchen and Jim is lighting the candle and we talked about safety meeting lit candle. Yeah, yeah.
《大西洋帝国》和《最响亮的声音》中担任常驻角色。现在，我从这一集中发现了一个非常有趣的细节，安吉拉，我简直不敢相信我们第一次竟然错过了。什么？在8分35秒时，帕姆在厨房挂她自制的横幅，吉姆在点蜡烛，我们讨论过安全会议上点蜡烛的事。对，对。
Okay, in that scene, you can see our camera operator, Chris Workman over Oscar's shoulder. Get out. You can see him standing on an Apple box getting the shot. No way. Oh, I have to go back and see that box getting the shot. No way. Oh, I have to go back and see that. I love Chris. I know.
好吧，在那一幕里，你可以看到我们的摄像师克里斯·沃克曼在奥斯卡的肩膀后面。别开玩笑了。你可以看到他站在苹果箱上拍摄。不会吧。哦，我得回去看看那个箱子在拍摄。不会吧。哦，我得回去看看。我喜欢克里斯。我知道。
He made it in the show. Well, something I wish I'd brought up the first time was a deleted scene that we would have played at the end of the episode. It features Michael and Dwight having a conversation with one of Michael's new neighbors. And lady, it's so funny because it is Greg Daniels. I know.
他出现在节目里了。嗯，我希望第一次就提出来的一件事是一个删减片段，我们本可以在剧集结尾播放的。它讲述了迈克尔和德怀特与迈克尔的一位新邻居交谈。天哪，这太搞笑了，因为那个人是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我知道。
Let's hear it. Hello? Hello. How are you? I'm just about to close on 126 over there, and I guess we're gonna be neighbors. Very cool, very cool. So what's the vibe?
我们来听听。你好？你好。你好吗？我正准备买下那边126号的房子，我想我们要成为邻居了。太酷了，太酷了。那这里的氛围怎么样？
What's the vibe of this place? I don't know, it's pretty quiet. Oh, that's going to change. Why? Because I love to party. And I'm going to be partying my butt off at this place. Okay, but there's an 11 o'clock noise curfew. Hi, I'm Dwight Schrute, Mr. Scott's associate.
这个地方的氛围怎么样？我不知道，这里挺安静的。哦，那要变了。为什么？因为我喜欢派对。我打算在这个地方疯狂派对。好吧，但是这里有晚上11点的噪音宵禁。嗨，我是德怀特·舒鲁特，斯科特先生的助理。
Who's Mr. Scott? Him. I have a question about the property line. These two trees are pretty close together, but it looks to me like this one's more on your side, this one might be more on his. Yeah. What are you doing home in the middle of the day? I just came back for lunch. What are you having? I've got a hot pocket.
谁是斯科特先生？他。我有个关于地界的问题。这两棵树靠得太近了，但在我看来，这棵更靠近你这边，那棵可能更靠近他那边。是啊。你大白天在家干什么？我刚回来吃午饭。你吃什么？我有个热口袋。
What line of business are you in? I'm a salesman. Really? So am pocket. What line of business are you in? I'm a salesman. Really? So am I. What? I sell yarn. You're a yarn salesman? Yeah. I have a couple questions about the neighborhood. Have you had any problems with prostitution, crack dealing, gang violence, etc.? No.
你是做什么生意的？我是个推销员。真的吗？我也是。什么？我卖纱线。你是纱线推销员？是啊。我对这个社区有几个问题。你有没有遇到过卖淫、毒品交易、帮派暴力等问题？没有。
Here's a question for you. I have a convertible. Is it safe to park that in my driveway? All right. See you soon. Good guy. Okay. So the thing I love about it is that we have teased Greg for so long because a big portion of that was improvisation. When they say, what do you do for a living? He says, I'm a salesman. They say, what do you sell? And he says yarn. We have teased him about being a yarn salesman. And I think you can hear it in Steve's voice when Steve says, oh, you sell yarn? Also, I love that he said he was eating a hot pocket. And the other thing too is if you go and watch this, we both rewatched it.
问你个问题。我有一辆敞篷车。停在我的车道上安全吗？好的。回头见。好人。好吧。我喜欢这一点的原因是，我们取笑格雷格太久了，因为那很大一部分是即兴创作。当他们问，你是做什么工作的？他说，我是个推销员。他们问，你卖什么？他说纱线。我们一直拿他是纱线推销员这件事取笑他。我想你能在史蒂夫的声音里听出来，当史蒂夫说，哦，你卖纱线？另外，我喜欢他说他在吃热口袋。还有一件事，如果你去看看这一集，我们俩都重看了。
When Dwight's like, I want to discuss a property line here, they are zero lot condos. So there's no yard. Do you know what I mean? It's like your door is to the left and the other person's door is to the right. And Greg's reactions were really funny. Oh, well, everyone, that was your second drink of Office Olympics. Join us this Wednesday for Is Toby the Scranton Strangler? Yep, and Jenna and I will discuss fan theories and debate if Toby really is the Scranton Strangler, and Paul Lieberstein is going to join us to talk all about it. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
当德怀特说，我想讨论一下这里的地界时，它们是零地块公寓。所以没有院子。你明白我的意思吗？就像你的门在左边，另一个人的门在右边。格雷格的反应真的很有趣。哦，好了，各位，这就是你们的第二杯《办公室奥运会》饮品。本周三加入我们，讨论《托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手吗？》。是的，我和珍娜将讨论粉丝理论，并辩论托比是否真的是斯克兰顿勒杀手，保罗·利伯斯坦将加入我们一起讨论。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everybody. Hi everyone. Welcome to season two, episode three Hi, everyone.
我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨，大家好。欢迎来到第二季第三集。嗨，大家好。
Welcome to season two, episode three, Office Olympics. Guys, if I sound grouchy today, it's because I'm in hour four of a cleanse. I've never done one before. I think they're stupid. I don't know why I'm doing it. Angela, what are your thoughts on my cleanse? It's a bad idea. Why am I doing it?
欢迎来到第二季第三集，《办公室奥运会》。伙计们，如果我今天听起来很暴躁，那是因为我正在进行排毒疗程的第四个小时。我以前从没做过。我觉得它们很蠢。我不知道我为什么要这么做。安吉拉，你对我的排毒疗程有什么看法？这是个坏主意。我为什么要这么做？
I don't know. I don't know. Whatever. So what are your thoughts on my cleanse? It's a bad idea. Why am I doing it? I don't know. I don't know. Whatever. I don't want a bunch of people writing in like to us being like, you guys, cleanses are good for you. But you know what? I just think they sound like a big pain in the ass.
我不知道。我不知道。随便吧。所以你对我的排毒疗程有什么看法？这是个坏主意。我为什么要这么做？我不知道。我不知道。随便吧。我不想让一群人写信给我们说，你们这些家伙，排毒对你们有好处。但你知道吗？我只是觉得它们听起来很烦人。
Here's the thing. I was running out of the house this morning. I was late. I didn't have time to make my usual breakfast of scrambled eggs and sliced strawberries. I eat that every morning. Oh man. I love it every morning. Oh man. I love it. Didn't have time.
事情是这样的。我今天早上急着出门。我迟到了。我没时间做我通常的早餐——炒蛋和草莓片。我每天早上都吃那个。哦，天哪。我每天早上都喜欢它。哦，天哪。我每天早上都喜欢它。没时间了。
But I remembered that about eight months ago, I ordered this five day cleanse at the advice of one of my friends. Who's like healthy or something. Super healthy, looks amazing, skin is amazing. And I thought, well, maybe today's the day. Maybe this is a sign. So I just grabbed day one of the cleanse.
但我记得大约八个月前，在一位朋友的建议下，我订购了这个五天的排毒疗程。她很健康什么的。超级健康，看起来棒极了，皮肤也棒极了。我想，好吧，也许今天就是那一天。也许这是一个信号。所以我只是拿了排毒疗程的第一天。
It's like a little pre-packaged, you know, I had a nut bar for breakfast. She looks like she's going into outer space. You guys, she has a little box. You've got like, it looks like compressed food, compressed food in this little foil packet. I've already, I guess, cheated. I hate that. I hate that I'm shaming myself over this thing already,. I've already, I guess cheated. I hate that. I hate that I'm shaming myself over this thing already,
就像一个小包装，你知道，我早餐吃了一根坚果棒。她看起来像是要去外太空。伙计们，她有一个小盒子。你有那种看起来像压缩食品的东西，在这个小铝箔袋里。我已经，我想，作弊了。我讨厌这个。我讨厌我因为这件事已经在羞辱自己了。我已经，我想，作弊了。我讨厌这个。我讨厌我因为这件事已经在羞辱自己了，
but I'm having coffee. You're not supposed to have coffee on the cleanse. You're supposed to have tea. It's not even caffeinated tea. What am I supposed to do with that? What is wrong with these people? That's what I'm saying. I don't know.
但我正在喝咖啡。排毒期间你不应该喝咖啡。你应该喝茶。甚至不是含咖啡因的茶。我该拿那个怎么办？这些人怎么了？我就是这么说的。我不知道。
And I already decided I think I'm gonna eat a full meal for dinner. I don't know. Well, I won't tell you what I brought for lunch. What? Pasta? I brought pasta. Oh my gosh. I have like freeze-dried soup to eat. I know. I know you're going into outer space. You're eating your packets. Why am I even saying I'm doing a cleanse when I've already planned to eat dinner tonight? I'm not doing I'm kind of doing a cleanse. I hate to break it to you. I'm not doing, I'm kind of doing a cleanse. What am I doing? I hate to break it to you. You're not doing a cleanse.
而且我已经决定了，我想我晚餐要吃顿饱饭。我不知道。好吧，我不会告诉你我午餐带了什么。什么？意大利面？我带了意大利面。天哪。我有那种冷冻干燥的汤要吃。我知道。我知道你要去外太空了。你在吃你的包装食品。为什么我明明已经计划好今晚吃晚餐了，还要说我在做排毒疗程？我没在做，我只是在做某种排毒。我不想打击你。我没在做，我只是在做某种排毒。我到底在干什么？我不想打击你。你根本没在做排毒。
You were rushing and you grabbed your NASA packets because you bought them and you feel bad that you bought them. That is it. And they've been sitting there. Yes. And also what I'm learning about you, Jenna, like I already knew this about you,
你当时很匆忙，抓了你的NASA包装食品，因为你买了它们，而且你因为买了它们而感到难过。就是这样。而且它们一直放在那里。是的。还有我正在了解关于你的一件事，珍娜，就像我已经了解你的那样，
but boy am I learning it now being your business partner is that if your routine gets thrown, you love routine, it sends you into this like spiral where all of a sudden you're like, like if you're like, oh, I didn't get my scrambled eggs and my strawberries. Do you know what I'm gonna do? I'm gonna move to Arizona.
但现在作为你的商业伙伴，我真的了解到了，如果你的日常习惯被打乱——你热爱日常习惯——这会让你陷入一种螺旋，突然间你会觉得，比如如果你说，哦，我没吃到我的炒蛋和草莓。你知道我会做什么吗？我要搬到亚利桑那州去。
What? Is so true. I've so thrown that I start to make really wack-a-doo decisions. Yeah, you make some big swings. Okay. All right. Well, you make some big swings. Okay. All right, well, let's see how it goes today. On that note.
什么？太真实了。我太慌乱了，以至于我开始做出非常疯狂的决定。是的，你做了一些大的变动。好吧。好吧，让我们看看今天进展如何。说到这里。
This episode, as I said, is Office Olympics, written by Mike Schurr and directed by Paul Fiegg. Yay! Let me give a summary. In this episode, Michael has to leave the office for the day to sign papers on his new condo. He's becoming a homeowner, everyone. Dwight goes with him, leaving Jim in charge, who decides to use the day to stage Office
这一集，正如我所说，是《办公室奥运会》，由迈克·舒尔编剧，保罗·费格执导。耶！让我总结一下。在这一集中，迈克尔必须离开办公室一天去签署他新公寓的文件。他要成为房主了，各位。德怀特和他一起去了，把吉姆留下来负责，吉姆决定利用这一天举办办公室
Olympics with the employees. Fast fact number one. Office Olympics was inspired by the King of the Hill Office Olympics. Yes. The writers on Greg's show, King of the Hill, created a real office Olympics and that is what inspired our episode. Actually, Jenna, it wasn't the writers
奥运会。事实一。《办公室奥运会》的灵感来自《山丘之王》的办公室奥运会。是的。格雷格剧组的编剧们，《山丘之王》的编剧们，创造了一个真正的办公室奥运会，这就是启发我们这一集的灵感。其实，珍娜，并不是编剧们
that invented the office Olympics for King of the Hill. It was Tim Crosston, Greg's assistant. Oh. Tim Crosston was Greg Daniel's assistant. Tim was also a long time friend of mine. I've known him for years. And Tim and two other assistants are who set up the whole Office Olympics at King of the Hill. The writers,
为《山丘之王》发明了办公室奥运会。是蒂姆·克罗斯顿，格雷格的助理。哦。蒂姆·克罗斯顿是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的助理。蒂姆也是我多年的朋友。我认识他很多年了。蒂姆和另外两名助理是整个《山丘之王》办公室奥运会的策划者。编剧们，
yes, participated, Jenna. Okay. They participated, but Tim was the mastermind. He was the self-appointed commissioner. Oh. Yes. And I- He was the gym. He was the gym. And I talked to him last night. We traded text messages. And Tim, sorry if I woke you up at 11 o'clock at night in North Carolina, but thank you for responding. They had a whole opening ceremonies. They had a torch. They had shirts for different teams. What?
是的，参与了，珍娜。好吧。他们参与了，但蒂姆是策划者。他是自封的专员。哦。是的。而且我——他是吉姆。他是吉姆。我昨晚和他谈过了。我们交换了短信。蒂姆，抱歉如果我在北卡罗来纳州晚上11点把你吵醒了，但谢谢你的回复。他们有完整的开幕式。他们有火炬。他们有不同队伍的衬衫。什么？
Yeah, they marched through the hallways. They had like a banner each team carried. They had a full opening ceremonies. And you know the doves that you see at the end for our closing ceremonies? Yes. They had that. They had doves that went across. They had several games that they had to play. It took a day and a half, this office Olympics. What were they not doing during this day and a half? I know. Well, Tim said that we wasted a full day and a half on this, and I won the award for wasting the most office time. So he said, so overall, I'm very proud of my time on King of the Hill.
是的，他们穿过走廊。他们每队都带着横幅。他们有完整的开幕式。你知道我们在闭幕式上看到的鸽子吗？是的。他们有那个。他们有飞过的鸽子。他们必须玩几个游戏。这花了整整一天半的时间，这个办公室奥运会。他们在这一天半里没做什么？我知道。嗯，蒂姆说我们在这上面浪费了整整一天半，我赢得了浪费最多办公室时间的奖项。所以他说，总的来说，我为我在《山丘之王》的时间感到非常自豪。
He said some of the games they had were mini golf through the office, Kerplunk, which was like this game, I guess where they had like sticks like in like a tube and you drop marbles down and then you had to twist it. I don't know. And then it went Kerplunk. Tim's favorite game that they had though
他说他们玩的一些游戏包括办公室迷你高尔夫、Kerplunk，这是一种游戏，我想就像他们把棍子插在管子里，你把弹珠放进去，然后你必须转动它。我不知道。然后它就发出Kerplunk的声音。不过蒂姆最喜欢的游戏是
was Guess the Elevator. And that they had though was guess the elevator. And that made it into our episode. Yes. So someone went down to the lobby and then came up and you had to guess which elevator they came out. So he said that was his personal favorite. They also had a Twinkie eating contest and Paul Lieberstein came in second.
猜电梯。那进入了我们的剧集。是的。所以有人下到大厅，然后上来，你必须猜他们从哪部电梯出来。所以他说那是他个人的最爱。他们还有一个吃Twinkie比赛，保罗·利伯斯坦得了第二名。
Go Paul. Cause Paul was working on King of the Hill at the time as well. But he said they really got into it. They went all out and he said one of the things that blew him away was Chuck Mangione. He is a famous musician, composer, Jenna. He actually played a recurring character on King of the Hill as himself, as the celebrity spokesperson for the Megalomart. Yes. And he flew himself out on his own dime to play.
加油保罗。因为保罗当时也在《山丘之王》工作。但他确实说他们真的很投入。他们全力以赴，他说让他震惊的一件事是查克·曼吉奥尼。他是一位著名的音乐家、作曲家，珍娜。他实际上在《山丘之王》中饰演了一个常驻角色，饰演他自己，作为Megalomart的名人代言人。是的。他自费飞过来参加开幕式，
He plays the flugelhorn and the trumpet to play at the opening ceremonies because he in fact actually played at the Olympics in Lake Placid, New York. This is crazy. How many years did they do this? Do we know? This was an annual thing, right? I don't know that. I don't know that.
他吹奏富鲁格号和小号，在开幕式上演奏，因为他实际上在纽约普莱西德湖的奥运会上演奏过。这太疯狂了。他们做了多少年？我们知道吗？这是一个年度活动，对吧？我不知道。我不知道。
I think, I mean, from what Tim texted me, they definitely went full out one year. I don't know if they could sustain this because I think they did waste a lot of time not working. And here's a random piece of trivia for you. I did a voice on King of the Hill. I had like a one line in the mega low-mart where I said, we don't sail super squatters no more on account of they're dangerous.
我想，嗯，从蒂姆发给我的短信来看，他们确实有一年全力以赴了。我不知道他们是否能维持下去，因为我想他们确实浪费了很多时间没工作。这里有一个关于你的随机琐事。我在《山丘之王》里配过音。我在Megalomart里有一句台词，我说，我们不再卖超级蹲坑者了，因为它们很危险。
So there's my connection there. Can you believe that? They really went all out on King of the Hill for their office Olympics. And that was the inspiration for office Olympics on the office. I love all of that information. That was amazing. Also, this episode ended up inspiring offices around the country to do their own Office Olympics. I mean, this got even bigger than just our TV show. Tim, you really started something. Thank you for that legacy, and thank you for letting me text you till almost midnight last night. Your time.
所以这就是我的联系。你能相信吗？他们在《山丘之王》里真的为他们的办公室奥运会全力以赴了。这就是《办公室》中办公室奥运会的灵感来源。我喜欢所有这些信息。太棒了。此外，这一集最终激励了全国各地的办公室举办他们自己的办公室奥运会。我的意思是，这甚至比我们的电视节目还要大。蒂姆，你真的开启了一些东西。谢谢你的遗产，也谢谢你让我昨晚给你发短信到快午夜。你的时间。
Fast fact number two, writer Mike Schur makes a cameo appearance in this episode. Oh, yeah. Appearing in a photograph as Dwight's Amish cousin, Moe's. Moe's was actually based on a character in the UPN show Amish in the City. It came out July 2004. Jenna, I went down the rabbit hole last night and I watched the pilot episode of Amish in the City because I wanted to see what the character of Mo's, there is a guy named Mo's. First of all, the premise for the show is crazy.
事实二，编剧迈克·舒尔在这一集中客串出演。哦，是的。出现在一张照片里，饰演德怀特的阿米什表弟莫斯。莫斯实际上是基于UPN节目《阿米什人在城市》中的一个角色。它于2004年7月播出。珍娜，我昨晚掉进了兔子洞，看了《阿米什人在城市》的试播集，因为我想看看莫斯这个角色，确实有一个叫莫斯的家伙。首先，这个节目的前提就很疯狂。
They take five Amish teens who are on their Rum Shringa, you know, they can go and live in the world for a year. And then they- In the non Amish world. Right, and then they decide if they wanna actually take the Amish way of life, right? So they take five Amish teens and they put them in a house in Los Angeles, like right off Ventura Boulevard, overlooking the city,
他们带了五个正在经历“Rum Shringa”的阿米什青少年，你知道，他们可以去外面的世界生活一年。然后他们——在非阿米什世界。对，然后他们决定是否真的要选择阿米什的生活方式，对吧？所以他们带了五个阿米什青少年，把他们放在洛杉矶的一所房子里，就在文图拉大道旁边，俯瞰城市，
and they put five mainstream American like teenagers. And now I think just taking five Amish kids to Los Angeles is enough. You got to throw in, there's a guy from Boston who's like, all I want to do was like, get laid and potty, woohoo! And you're going to put him with Moe's. Moe's who like brought his wooden puzzles
然后他们放了五个主流的美国青少年。现在我觉得光是带五个阿米什孩子去洛杉矶就够了。你还得加上，有一个来自波士顿的家伙，他就像，我只想做爱和派对，呜呼！你要把他和莫斯放在一起。莫斯，他带来了他自己做的木制拼图，
that he made himself. I mean, there's a whole scene where he's like, do you like puzzles? And the Boston guy's like, nah, I don't like them. And he's like, oh, that's pretty much all I brought. Oh my gosh. This, okay, sorry. Your explanation of Amish in the City is making me want to watch Amish in the City.
有一整场戏是他问，你喜欢拼图吗？波士顿那个家伙说，不，我不喜欢。他说，哦，那基本上是我带来的全部东西。天哪。这个，好吧，抱歉。你对《阿米什人在城市》的解释让我很想看《阿米什人在城市》。
I'm very invested in Moe's. I feel like I'm going to have to go back because I'm like, what happened to Moe's and his puzzles? How's he doing? Well, I guess the writers were obsessed with Amish in the City as well. And the entire first season of The Office, they would all talk about it. And so finally, when we got a season two, they, that was their way of honoring their love of Amish in the city, was this character of Moe's that Mike Schur, I think he
我非常关注莫斯。我觉得我得回去看看，因为我在想，莫斯和他的拼图怎么了？他过得怎么样？嗯，我想编剧们也对《阿米什人在城市》着迷。在《办公室》的第一季，他们一直在谈论它。所以最后，当我们有了第二季，他们，那是他们向对《阿米什人在城市》的热爱致敬的方式，就是这个莫斯的角色，迈克·舒尔，我想他
thought he was just appearing in a photograph. Little did he know he would go on to play this character for nine years. For nine years, and then probably would have been in the spin-off, The Farm, had it happened. True. He would still be playing Moe's. Of course. We also introduce another recurring character in this episode. It is the realtor. Yes, Carole Stills. Carole Stills played by Nancy Carell, Steve Carell's wife. Who is hilarious. Nancy is hilarious and we will talk more about her scenes with Steve as we get into this episode. Fast fact number three, this was our first time working with director Paul Fiegg.
以为他只是出现在一张照片里。他没想到他会继续扮演这个角色九年。九年，然后如果衍生剧《农场》发生的话，他可能也会在里面。真的。他还会继续扮演莫斯。当然。我们在这一集中还引入了另一个常驻角色。是房地产经纪人。是的，卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯。卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯由南希·卡瑞尔饰演，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的妻子。她太搞笑了。南希太搞笑了，当我们进入这一集时，我们会更多地谈论她和史蒂夫的对手戏。事实三，这是我们第一次与导演保罗·费格合作。
Yay! Who is undoubtedly one of our favorite directors. Paul is so brilliant and what I love is he's kind. He's just a delightful person to be around. We've talked a little bit about how he and his wife, Laurie, would host our viewing parties. But this was our first time working with him. And I'll never forget when he walked on set,
耶！他无疑是我们最喜欢的导演之一。保罗太聪明了，我喜欢的是他很善良。他是一个非常令人愉快的人。我们谈过一点他和他的妻子劳里是如何举办我们的观看派对的。但这是我们第一次和他合作。我永远不会忘记他走进片场的时候，
because he was wearing a full suit and tie. Oh, he is so dapper. Which he wore every day. Every day. Every day he wore a suit. A lot of them were like vintage suits. So they were also super cool. They weren't stuffy.
因为他穿着全套西装和领带。哦，他太时髦了。他每天都穿。每天。他每天都穿西装。很多都是复古西装。所以它们也超级酷。它们一点也不沉闷。
I mean, they were like super hip. No, he and his wife Lori are like, they're like a smart looking couple. Yeah. They look like people who read The New Yorker, don't they? Like, they're super smart. They can read the long articles because those articles are super long. There's really smart. And their house, I remember, was like decorated like decorated like so lovely like they had art.
我的意思是，它们超级时髦。不，他和他的妻子劳里就像，他们看起来是一对很聪明的夫妇。是的。他们看起来像是读《纽约客》的人，不是吗？就像，他们超级聪明。他们能读长文章，因为那些文章超级长。真的很聪明。而且他们的房子，我记得，装饰得非常可爱，他们有艺术品。
Yes, yes. But they're not stuffy people. You know what I mean? They're incredibly approachable. Not flashy. Yeah, not flashy. They're just really nice people and Paul was one of my absolute favorite directors we ever had. You are in love with his Instagram. I am. His Instagram. She is obsessed with his Instagram. I love his Instagram. It makes me with his Instagram. I love his Instagram.
是的，是的。但他们不是沉闷的人。你明白我的意思吗？他们非常平易近人。不浮夸。是的，不浮夸。他们只是非常好的人，保罗是我绝对最喜欢的导演之一。你爱上了他的Instagram。我是。他的Instagram。她沉迷于他的Instagram。我喜欢他的Instagram。它让我——他的Instagram。我喜欢他的Instagram。
It makes me wanna travel and dress nice and have a cocktail. Yes, yes, this is true. Paul Feig before this had worked on Freaks and Geeks, which I was a huge fan of. And actually Freaks and Geeks is the very first television show I ever auditioned for. I wondered if you auditioned for that. That seemed like right in your will house.
它让我想要旅行，穿得漂亮，喝杯鸡尾酒。是的，是的，这是真的。保罗·费格在此之前曾参与过《怪胎与书呆》，我是它的超级粉丝。事实上，《怪胎与书呆》是我试镜的第一部电视剧。我一直在想你是否试镜过那个。那看起来就在你的好球区。
I did not audition for one of the regular characters. The show had already happened, but I went in for a guest appearance, I think just three lines. And this was because Alison Jones, who cast the office, also cast Freaks and Geeks. This started my relationship with Alison Jones. I went in, I auditioned for Freaks and Geeks,
我没有试镜常规角色。节目已经开始了，但我去客串了一个角色，我想只有三句台词。这是因为艾莉森·琼斯，她为《办公室》选角，也为《怪胎与书呆》选角。这开启了我和艾莉森·琼斯的关系。我去了，我试镜了《怪胎与书呆》，
I did not get the role. That's all right, lady. That's all right. It happens sometimes. She called me back later for a TV show called Undeclared that was produced by Judd Apatow, and I did get that part, just one line. And then, you know, five years later,
我没得到那个角色。没关系，女士。没关系。有时会发生这种情况。她后来又叫我参加了一个叫《不学无术》的电视节目，由贾德·阿帕图制作，我得到了那个角色，只有一句台词。然后，你知道，五年后，
she called me to audition for the office. Wow. That was all Alison Jones. But I almost worked with Paul Feig on Freaks and Geeks, but it didn't happen. But it was meant to be. Our paths would cross. Little did I know.
她打电话让我试镜《办公室》。哇。那全是艾莉森·琼斯的功劳。但我差点和保罗·费格在《怪胎与书呆》中合作，但没成。但这是命中注定的。我们的道路会交叉。我当时根本不知道。
And they did. But Paul also directed Bridesmaids, one of my all-time favorite movies. So funny. I remember going to that premiere, because we were so excited to support Paul and to support Ellie. And the whole cast was just phenomenal. and I was so happy for him and you know Paul is the type of
他们确实交叉了。但保罗还执导了《伴娘》，我最喜欢的电影之一。太搞笑了。我记得去参加那个首映式，因为我们非常兴奋能支持保罗和艾莉。整个演员阵容简直太棒了。我为他感到非常高兴，你知道保罗是那种
guy the minute he sees you this huge smile comes across his face and he gives you a big hug and he's just he's just such a giving person of his self you know and I was so happy to support him and so happy that it ended up being such a huge hit. I want to call your attention to Paul Feig's many books that are amazing. Okay, he wrote Kick Me, which is, I guess it's like his autobiography. For the first chapter of his life. Yeah, about his adolescence. Yeah, I really feel like he could write a whole bunch more.
家伙，当你看到他时，他脸上会露出灿烂的笑容，他会给你一个大大的拥抱，他是一个非常慷慨的人，你知道，我很高兴支持他，也很高兴它最终成为如此巨大的成功。我想提请你注意保罗·费格写的许多书，它们都很棒。好吧，他写了《踢我》，我想那是他的自传。关于他生命的第一章。是的，关于他的青春期。是的，我真的觉得他可以写更多。
But he's so funny. The book is amazing. And then he also wrote this book called Super Stud or How I Became a 24 Year Old Virgin. It's also amazing. So you guys really, if you want to dive deep on Paul Feig, I recommend these books. Guess what we did? We called Paul Feig for this episode. Who is singing? What has this cleanse done to me?
但他太搞笑了。这本书太棒了。然后他还写了一本叫《超级书呆》或《我是如何成为24岁处男的》。它也很棒。所以你们，如果你们想深入了解保罗·费格，我推荐这些书。猜猜我们做了什么？我们为这一集给保罗·费格打了电话。谁在唱歌？这个排毒疗程对我做了什么？
It's turned me into you. It's turning you into me and you're about to make some crazy life choices. Should we go to a bar right now? No, God no, we should not. That's horrible, it's 11 a.m. also. Probably defeats the purpose of your cleanse. Guys, we called Paul Feig and we interviewed him about Office Olympics.
它把你变成了我。它正在把你变成我，你即将做出一些疯狂的人生选择。我们要现在去酒吧吗？不，上帝不，我们不应该。那太可怕了，现在才上午11点。而且可能违背了你排毒的目的。伙计们，我们给保罗·费格打了电话，采访了他关于《办公室奥运会》的事。
We even included some of your questions. So after the break, we're going to talk to Paul Feig. We're going to ask him some questions. He's going to tell us about Office Olympics. I can't wait. All right. Stay tuned. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate.
我们甚至包括了你们的一些问题。所以休息后，我们要和保罗·费格谈谈。我们要问他一些问题。他会告诉我们关于《办公室奥运会》的事。我等不及了。好吧。敬请期待。从房地产商那里送货上门。
Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. Get groceries delivered across the DTA from real estate. I can't wait. All right, stay tuned. All right, we are back and we are going to be talking to Paul Feig. Sam, dial him up. Hello. Hi, Paul. Hey, Paul. How are you?
从房地产商那里送货上门。从房地产商那里送货上门。从房地产商那里送货上门。从房地产商那里送货上门。从房地产商那里送货上门。从房地产商那里送货上门。我等不及了。好吧，敬请期待。好吧，我们回来了，我们要和保罗·费格谈谈。萨姆，拨通他的电话。你好。嗨，保罗。嘿，保罗。你好吗？
I'm good. How are you? Are you somewhere fancy, Paul? No, I'm in New York, actually. Yeah, but are you somewhere fancy? Well, my apartment is very fancy because I'm married. Thank you so much for doing this, Paul. It really means a lot.
我很好。你好吗？你在什么高档的地方吗，保罗？不，我其实在纽约。是的，但你在什么高档的地方吗？嗯，我的公寓非常高档，因为我结婚了。非常感谢你做这件事，保罗。这真的意义重大。
Thank you. I'm so glad you're here. I'm so glad you're here. I'm so glad you're here. I'm so glad you're here. I'm so glad you're here. I'm so New York, actually. Yeah, but are you somewhere fancy? Well, my apartment's very fancy. Because I'm very fancy. Thank you so much for doing this, Paul. It really means a lot. Oh, my God, I'm so excited. I'm so happy that you guys are doing this. And I wish I could be in the studio with you.
谢谢。我很高兴你在这里。我很高兴你在这里。我很高兴你在这里。我很高兴你在这里。我很高兴你在这里。我很高兴你其实在纽约。是的，但你在什么高档的地方吗？嗯，我的公寓非常高档。因为我非常高档。非常感谢你做这件事，保罗。这真的意义重大。哦，天哪，我太兴奋了。我很高兴你们在做这个。我真希望我能和你们在录音室里。
It would be so much even more fun. Well, you're always welcome to come back. We've got 200 episodes to talk about. And you directed a great deal of them. Oh, good. I'll talk on deal of them. Oh good, exactly. I'll talk on all of mine. We'll hit you up for that. We actually reached out to some fans to talk to you today and there were people who had so many questions.
那会更有趣。好吧，随时欢迎你回来。我们有200集要谈。你执导了其中很大一部分。哦，好。我谈论其中一部分。哦，好，没错。我会谈论我所有的。我们会为此联系你。我们实际上联系了一些粉丝今天和你谈谈，有很多人有这么多问题。
Yeah, so we're gonna include some of their questions with our questions. Very good, I'm excited. Well, to get started, Paul, how did you get involved with the office? It was my great agent at the time, Renee Kurtz, who was steering me towards it. I honestly, I was offered several years before the chance to develop the office, you know, the British office, into a series.
是的，所以我们要把他们的一些问题和我们的问题结合起来。很好，我很兴奋。好吧，开始吧，保罗，你是怎么参与《办公室》的？是我当时的伟大经纪人蕾妮·库尔茨，她引导我走向它。老实说，我在几年前就被提供了开发《办公室》，你知道，英国版《办公室》，改编成系列剧的机会。
And I was like, oh, forget it. There's no way you can do it. It's too scary, you know, because it's such a great series. So, you know, I just didn't even take the bait. But then when Greg did it, you know, I was really, you know, amazed by that. And actually, the funny thing is I was making a pilot at the same time that Greg did the pilot for the office. And I remember we were she we were both working at like some studio and he was editing there. And I remember we were we were both working at like some studio and he was editing there and I remember him coming over to us To Rodney Rothman and I whose pilot it was he's like hey come in here come in here I gotta play you a couple of different options for the opening theme song for for this show that I just directed
我当时想，哦，算了吧。你不可能做到。这太可怕了，你知道，因为它是一个如此伟大的系列。所以，你知道，我甚至没有上钩。但当格雷格做的时候，你知道，我真的，你知道，对此感到惊讶。事实上，有趣的是，我在格雷格为《办公室》制作试播集的同时也在制作一个试播集。我记得我们当时都在某个工作室工作，他在那里剪辑。我记得我们当时都在某个工作室工作，他在那里剪辑，我记得他走过来对我和罗德尼·罗斯曼说，这是谁的试播集，他说，嘿，进来，进来，我得给你们放几个不同的选项，作为我刚执导的这个节目的开场主题曲。
Yes, so he played us a couple of different versions including the you know the one that the now infamous piano one So I was I was definitely definitely there at the very beginning you know what when the show got picked up my agent call me renee and she was like you know they'd like you to direct an episode and and so i watched i watched the first six that you guys had done and thought they were so hilarious you know it's in the diversity day i was just like completely and i just thought it was so great. Yeah, I came to that first table read.
是的，所以他给我们放了几个不同的版本，包括那个，你知道，现在臭名昭著的钢琴版。所以我绝对，绝对是在最开始就在那里，你知道，当节目被选中时，我的经纪人蕾妮打电话给我，她说，你知道，他们想让你执导一集，所以我看了，我看了你们做的前六集，觉得它们太搞笑了，你知道，在《多元化日》那一集，我只是觉得完全，我只是觉得它太棒了。是的，我参加了第一次剧本朗读会。
I don't know if you remember, they did kind of a bunch of episodes all at once. I remember you guys were reading the Dundee's and all that, and then we read Office Olympics. So I was in. Did you get to pick Office Olympics from that table read or was it assigned to you? Yeah, that was the one that was assigned to me because I remember having a moment going like, oh, I want to do the Dundee's. That seems really fun. But then I just saw the potential of the Office Olympics was just going to be such a blast.
我不知道你是否记得，他们一次做了很多集。我记得你们在读《邓迪奖》什么的，然后我们读了《办公室奥运会》。所以我加入了。你是从那次剧本朗读会上挑选了《办公室奥运会》，还是分配给你的？是的，那是分配给我的，因为我记得当时有一个时刻，心想，哦，我想做《邓迪奖》。那看起来真的很有趣。但后来我看到了《办公室奥运会》的潜力，那将会是一场爆炸。
I mean, it was just such a fun thing to kind of put together. I remember just what an interesting, I don't know, what an interesting feeling it was on the set for that. Because I mean, if you remember that was sort of, you know, aside from the Olympics part of it, that was the episode that kind of started to turn everything because that's where, you know, Steve's character started to become slightly more sympathetic. And I don't know if you remember or not, we really, that kinda got found on the set because remember we were doing the whole thing where we were presenting, you guys are presenting Michael with the, you know, with the metal
我的意思是，这真是一件很有趣的事情。我记得在片场那种有趣的感觉，我不知道，那是什么感觉。因为我的意思是，如果你记得那在某种程度上，你知道，除了奥运会部分，那是开始改变一切的一集，因为那是，你知道，史蒂夫的角色开始变得稍微更令人同情的地方。我不知道你是否记得，我们真的，那是在片场发现的，因为记得我们当时在做整个事情，你们在给迈克尔颁发，你知道，奖牌，
and Steve just made this decision to kinda start crying you know, getting all choked up and I remember just going like, oh my god Steve that's so great like keep going with that. And that was, I think that was kind of the turning point where his character took that left turn from Ricky Gervais' character and became more sort of the lovable misfit who's trying too hard for everybody to like him.
史蒂夫只是做出了这个决定，开始哭泣，你知道，哽咽了，我记得我只是说，哦，天哪，史蒂夫，那太棒了，继续那样做。我想那是他的角色从瑞奇·热维斯的角色转弯，变成更像是一个可爱的、试图让每个人都喜欢他的不合群者的转折点。
But also Paul, I remember in that filming of that scene that you directed all of us to be genuine and You can see it on our faces that we are genuinely clapping for Michael. We're not mocking him It was this collective moment with everyone in the office enjoying Supporting one another it was really sweet. It makes me tear up every time I watch it I cried when Steve did that, yeah. No, it really gets me too. Because I think, you know what it was?
但保罗，我也记得在拍摄那场戏时，你指导我们所有人要真诚，你可以从我们的脸上看到我们是真诚地为迈克尔鼓掌。我们不是在嘲笑他。这是办公室里每个人享受支持彼此的集体时刻，真的很甜。每次我看它，我都会流泪。史蒂夫那样做时，我哭了，是的。不，它真的也让我很感动。因为我想，你知道那是什么吗？
It was just Steve's performance was so sincere that it felt, if we were kind of being snarky or laughing at him, that it made you guys such villains to do that. But it wasn't anybody's really instinct to do that. So I just kind of encourage you to go along with what you were already doing, which is we were all really being affected by Steve. Yeah, yeah, yeah, it still gets me. Well, we have a fan question for you.
这只是史蒂夫的表演太真诚了，如果我们要么尖酸刻薄，要么嘲笑他，那会让你们成为那样做的恶棍。但没有人真的有那种本能。所以我只是鼓励你们继续做你们已经在做的事情，那就是我们都被史蒂夫感动了。是的，是的，是的，它仍然让我感动。好吧，我们有一个粉丝问题给你。
Reed wrote in and said, I know, ooh, Reed says, when filming a mockumentary, do you storyboard or do you have a shot plan? Neither. What you do is you basically kind of go through the script and I would walk around with Kelly, our AD, the day before or whatever, and we just basically kind of go,
里德写信说，我知道，哦，里德说，在拍摄伪纪录片时，你使用分镜还是有拍摄计划？都没有。你所做的是你基本上浏览剧本，我会在前一天或什么时候和我们的副导演凯利四处走动，我们基本上只是说，
okay, where would we put the cameras for this scene so that we would be cross shooting it and the cameras could avoid seeing each other, but where the documentary crew would actually be. And so you were always just kind of going, okay, you know, for me it's like I always want to have depth behind us, so I never wanted to shoot in the walls whenever I could avoid it. And so just kind of go, okay, they would be, you know, one would be over here by this desk
好吧，我们把摄像机放在哪里拍摄这一幕，这样我们就可以交叉拍摄，摄像机可以避免看到彼此，但纪录片摄制组实际上会在哪里。所以你总是只是在想，好吧，你知道，对我来说，我总是想在背后有深度，所以我尽可能避免对着墙拍摄。所以只是说，好吧，他们会，你知道，一个会在这里，在这个桌子旁边，
and then on the opposite side, something, you know, Matt would be over there and Randall would be on the other side something you know with the uh... matter would be over there and randall be on the other side and really that was that was kind of it then you also go like okay is this gonna be a spy shot where you guys don't know you're on camera will be shooting through you know the blinds are through a crack in the door uh... and that was kind of it and then then we would just get there and just play out the scene
然后在对面，什么，你知道，马特会在那里，兰德尔会在另一边，什么，你知道，马特会在那里，兰德尔会在另一边，真的，那就是全部了，然后你也会想，好吧，这会是一个间谍镜头吗，你们不知道你们在镜头里，我们会通过，你知道，百叶窗或门缝拍摄，嗯，那就是全部了，然后我们就会去那里，只是演完这一幕。
for me this is it's the greatest way to do TV comedy because it just every time we shot the scene we had the full scene and so it just allowed us to just play and go like okay this time try this you know and you know it in just the fact that Greg and everybody let us play around so much with these great scripts that we already had and then we had the confidence to keep that stuff in because I'd worked on other shows where the cast was really brilliant at kind of improving or tagging something or just kind of taking a little left turn in the middle of the
对我来说，这是拍摄电视喜剧最棒的方式，因为每次我们拍摄场景时，我们都有完整的剧本，这让我们能够自由发挥，比如“这次试试这个”，你知道的，格雷格和每个人都让我们在已有的精彩剧本基础上进行大量的即兴创作，而且我们有信心保留这些内容，因为我曾在其他节目工作过，那里的演员非常擅长即兴表演、增加笑点，或者在场景中间突然来个小转折，
scene but the showrunners just wouldn't put it in because they were so in love with their scripts so that they just wouldn't use it but you know I'm just I mean the keep the shining example of that was when we did the next episode, the Halloween episode, where we had that thing where we found what Rain was doing, playing the emperor and talking to Michael and kind of goading him. And we just found that funny angle
但剧集主管就是不肯把它放进去，因为他们太爱自己的剧本了，所以他们根本不用，但你知道，我指的是，最典型的例子就是我们拍下一集，也就是万圣节那一集的时候，我们发现了雷恩在做什么，他扮演皇帝，和迈克尔说话，还挑逗他。我们只是觉得那个角度很有趣，
that looked like the emperor from Star Wars, where you just gotta see his face. And we just, you know, him just taunt, and that went on and on. But Greg, I think, jettisoned some other kind of storyline, just so we could keep that scene long, because it was just so funny. And, you know, that takes a lot of confidence in sort of, you know, well, self-confidence, really, on the part of the showrunner to let those moments play out like that. I love that.
看起来就像《星球大战》里的皇帝，你必须看到他的脸。我们只是，你知道，他只是在嘲讽，这持续了很久。但格雷格，我想，他删掉了一些其他的故事情节，只是为了让我们保持那个场景的长度，因为它太搞笑了。而且，你知道，这需要剧集主管有很大的自信，真的，对自己有信心，才能让那些时刻那样展现出来。我喜欢那样。
Me too. I love hearing everything that went into how it ended up on screen. We were just acting, you did all this planning. I know. You put all this thought into it. Without you, we are nothing. Without you, we are nothing.
我也是。我喜欢听关于最终呈现在屏幕上的所有幕后故事。我们只是在演戏，而你做了所有的规划。我知道。你投入了所有的心思。没有你，我们什么都不是。没有你，我们什么都不是。
I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about picking the condo location in this episode because it's almost like Another character it features so prominently. What was the criteria for picking the condo? You wanted something that had enough Flow to it and openness that you weren't going to be stuck in little rooms, you know What just basically walls is your background. And so what I really liked about it is they had that kitchen that went through to the back patio. So you know, we were in the kitchen shooting Michael kind of having his breakdown, which
我想知道你能不能谈谈在这一集中选择公寓地点的事，因为它几乎就像另一个角色，它的出镜率太高了。选择公寓的标准是什么？你想要一个有足够的流动性和开放性的空间，这样你就不会被困在小房间里，你知道，基本上就是以墙壁为背景。所以我真正喜欢它的是，它有一个通往后院露台的厨房。所以你知道，我们在厨房里拍摄迈克尔崩溃的样子，这
is still possibly the, I think the hardest, I think I've ever laughed on a set. Yes. When Steven was having that thing where he's having the breakdown, he kind of puts his hand on the stove and picks up the thing and then goes outside. Is this supposed to come off? And he walks out with it. Oh, I mean, that is like just, that's the genius of Steve. I literally thought I was going to die when he was doing it. And every time we do a take, you do something different. Did we use that same condo in dinner party? Did we manage to keep that same place? It looked familiar. It looked very familiar to me, didn't it to you? in Dinner Party? Did we manage to keep that same place?
可能仍然是我在片场笑得最厉害的一次。是的。当史蒂夫在演那个崩溃的戏时，他把手放在炉子上，拿起那个东西，然后走到外面。这是要拆下来的吗？然后他拿着它走了出去。哦，我的天，那简直就是史蒂夫的天才之处。当他做那个动作时，我真的以为我要笑死了。而且每次我们拍一条，你都会做不同的动作。我们在《晚宴》那一集中用了同一个公寓吗？我们设法保留了同一个地方吗？它看起来很眼熟。它对我来说看起来非常眼熟，对你来说呢？在《晚宴》里？我们设法保留了同一个地方吗？
It looked familiar to me, didn't it to you? Like the kitchen. I thought it was the condo. Yeah. That's amazing. Well, what was fun about that is being able to go in and turn it into Jan's place. Yeah. And that was, I mean, I don't want to jump episodes,
它对我来说看起来很眼熟，对你来说呢？就像厨房。我以为那是那个公寓。是的。那太棒了。好吧，有趣的是能够进去并把它变成简的家。是的。我的意思是，我不想跳过剧集，
but I mean, for Dinner party, that was the most fun of like, how do we see how Jan's woman's touch went in with kimonos on the wall? Oh, my gosh, Paul, you have to come back, you have to come in. We will have so much fun with that. I was talking to Mike Sure about this episode. He was the writer of this episode. And he shared with us your choice of using a wide-angle lens when filming Steve for this episode. Can you talk a little bit about that? Yeah, it was just, you know, we really wanted him to feel lost in this thing because, you know, it's so much about him being overwhelmed. Yeah, I had a very similar experience when I first
但我的意思是，对于《晚宴》，最有趣的是，我们如何看到简的女性触觉是如何融入的，墙上挂着和服？哦，天哪，保罗，你必须回来，你必须进来。我们会玩得很开心的。我当时正在和迈克·舒尔谈论这一集。他是这一集的编剧。他与我们分享了你在拍摄史蒂夫这一集时使用广角镜头的选择。你能谈谈那个吗？是的，这只是，你知道，我们真的希望他在这件事中感到迷失，因为，你知道，这很大程度上是因为他感到不知所措。是的，我第一次见到洛瑞，也就是我妻子时，也有过非常相似的经历，
met Lori, my wife, and we were going to move in together you know and she'd found this place and i came over is under the guider just gonna like look at it and see what it's about and little did i know she can have the realtor there and everything and it like i had to sign the papers he did pull the trigger so suddenly i went from being like this kind of
我们打算住在一起，你知道，她找到了这个地方，我过来只是想看看它是什么样的，但我没想到她会把房地产经纪人也带到那里，一切都准备好了，就像我必须签字一样，他确实扣动了扳机，所以我突然从一个那种
weird lonely bachelor did like it committing to moving in in front of all these people and i just kind of freaked out and i remember that feeling of like so we the house felt very like uh... abstract and but you're in a horrible you're having a panic attack but i wanted to be big on that the field that being you know in that house of
奇怪的孤独单身汉，变成了在这些人面前承诺搬进去，我当时有点吓坏了，我记得那种感觉，所以我们，房子感觉非常，呃……抽象，但你当时处于一种可怕的状态，你正在经历恐慌发作，但我想要那种感觉很大，你知道，在那所房子里，
like it's almost like, you know, forget there's an old movie, that obsession, but something where this woman's going crazy in the house. I just thought it'd be kind of funny to give it that feel. Oh my gosh, I love that story. Laurie, you go, Laurie. I'm telling you, I know, look at that. We just celebrated our 25 year anniversary, wedding anniversary, so it works. Well we got a lot of questions also about the yogurt lids.
就像，几乎就像，你知道，忘了有一部老电影叫《孽迷宫》，但类似那种女人在房子里发疯的东西。我只是觉得给它那种感觉会很有趣。哦，天哪，我喜欢那个故事。洛瑞，你真棒，洛瑞。我告诉你，我知道，看看那个。我们刚刚庆祝了我们的25周年结婚纪念日，所以它奏效了。好吧，我们还收到了很多关于酸奶盖的问题。
This was maybe the thing people are most curious about, these yogurt lids. Oh my gosh, they went crazy about the yogurt lids, Paul. Mel wanted to know how many metals were made. Casey wants to know were any other items considered for metals before landing on yogurt lids? Literally any information you can give us about these yogurt lids. Anything about yogurt lids. People want to know. Wow, because I remember that so distinctly, just because I remember thinking it was not at all what I thought we were going to make the metal.
这可能是人们最好奇的事情，这些酸奶盖。哦，天哪，他们对酸奶盖简直着迷了，保罗。梅尔想知道一共做了多少个奖牌。凯西想知道在决定用酸奶盖之前，是否考虑过其他物品作为奖牌？真的，你能提供任何关于这些酸奶盖的信息。任何关于酸奶盖的事情。人们想知道。哇，因为我记得非常清楚，只是因为我记得当时想，这根本不是我想象中我们要制作奖牌的东西。
And I remember Phil, remember Phil Props coming up with those and I remember him rigging that up with the paper clips of the chain and hanging that out there. And I had moments of going like, I don't know if it's substantial enough cause they're so light, but then thinking, but this is kind of brilliant too.
我记得菲尔，记得道具师菲尔想出了那些东西，我记得他用回形针做链子把它们挂在那里。我有过怀疑的时刻，觉得它不够结实，因为它们太轻了，但后来又想，但这也很天才。
And so going with it, I have some weird memory, and I don't know if it's accurate or not, of like a cottage cheese Liz. Oh, it would be larger. Which was a little more freaky-like and bigger. Yes, but I think we might have said they were too big and also I think they didn't stay on the paper clip. So, but that's just a kind of a hazy memory. Steve Gordon asked, this is just kind of a fun question, which one of the freaks and geeks could work in the office?
所以就这么定了，我有一些奇怪的记忆，我不知道是否准确，关于一个干酪盖子。哦，那会更大。这有点更怪异，也更大。是的，但我认为我们可能说过它们太大了，而且我认为它们没法固定在回形针上。所以，但这只是一个模糊的记忆。史蒂夫·戈登问了一个有趣的问题，哪一个《怪胎与书呆子》里的角色可以在办公室工作？
I think it'd have to be Lindsay. I think only Lindsay could really pull it together inappropriately and navigate that maelstrom. I hear that. I think that is the right choice. I think that is correct. And then, okay, Paul, we have to bring up because Jenna and I love this about you so much that you wear a suit every day with a tie
我觉得必须是琳赛。我觉得只有琳赛能真正以不恰当的方式处理好一切，并驾驭那个大漩涡。我听到了。我觉得那是正确的选择。我觉得那是对的。然后，好吧，保罗，我们必须提一下，因为珍娜和我非常喜欢你这一点，那就是你每天都穿西装打领带，
and that our crew loved it so much. On Friday, a lot of times on a set, the crew will wear Hawaiian shirts, it's Friday, but when you would work, they would all wear a tie on Friday. And so we were wondering when did your origin of the daily suit start? It was after Freaks and Geeks,
而且我们的剧组非常喜欢它。周五，在片场，剧组人员通常会穿夏威夷衬衫，因为是周五，但当你工作时，他们周五都会打领带。所以我们想知道你每天穿西装的起源是什么时候开始的？是在《怪胎与书呆子》之后，
because I'll flash all the way back just briefly. When I was a kid, I used to wear suits and ties all the time. I loved that. That was kind of like starting at like eight years old. Aw. Like I got my mom to buy me my first three piece suit. And then I wore it. Oh, my dad was so mad because he's mad because like you can grow out of it in
因为我会简短地回顾一下。当我还是个孩子的时候，我一直穿西装打领带。我喜欢那样。那大概是从八岁开始的。啊。就像我让我妈妈给我买了我的第一套三件套西装。然后我就穿上了。哦，我爸爸非常生气，因为他很生气，因为你会在
six months and he was right but over the six months i have walking around with the suits so it was always in the but then when i got my twenties and i would be able to stand up comedian i'd i'd used to be used to wear it as suits on stage and then i'd realize i wanted to be more i don't know relatable to the audience i started wearing like jeans and bowling shirts and that kind of thing. And then when I did Freaks and Geeks, I, even though I didn't dress this
六个月内就穿不下了，他是对的，但在那六个月里，我穿着西装走来走去，所以它一直都在，但当我二十多岁，能够成为一名单口喜剧演员时，我过去常在舞台上穿西装，然后我意识到我想变得更，我不知道，更贴近观众，我开始穿牛仔裤和保龄球衫之类的东西。然后当我做《怪胎与书呆子》时，我，即使我高中时没有这样穿，
way in high school, I started dressing just like kind of t-shirts and jeans because I was trying to get in the head of like the freaks and stuff and so grew my hair really long. You can see pictures of me from then. My hair was super long, like down to my shoulder, I think. And so then it was after Freaks and Geeks was done and I was going out and pitching new shows and taking all these meetings that I was in the meetings and all the executives would be in suits and ties.
我开始穿得就像T恤和牛仔裤，因为我试图进入那些怪胎之类的角色的头脑，所以我把头发留得很长。你可以看到我当时的照片。我的头发超级长，我想大概垂到了肩膀。所以是在《怪胎与书呆子》结束后，我出去推销新节目并参加所有这些会议时，我在会议中，所有的主管都穿着西装打领带。
And I was there in jeans and a t-shirt and I just didn't like it. I felt like really identifiable as sort of the prey, if you will, in that room. And so I remember going like, well screw this, I'm gonna go back to what I used to do and wear suits and ties. I kind of thought I was an idiot for doing it, but I just remember going like, I like the power structure of this better, of me in a suit like as an adult, and just decided from that point on, I was like I'm just gonna wear a suit and tie all the time because I enjoy it and it makes me feel like an adult and also makes me feel in charge
而我穿着牛仔裤和T恤，我就是不喜欢那样。我觉得自己在那间屋子里真的被识别为某种猎物，如果你愿意这么说的话。所以我记得当时想，去他的，我要回到我过去做的事情，穿西装打领带。我当时觉得自己这样做是个白痴，但我只是记得当时想，我更喜欢这种权力结构，我作为一个成年人穿着西装，所以从那时起，我就决定我只是要一直穿西装打领带，因为我喜欢它，它让我感觉像个成年人，也让我感觉自己掌控一切，
and I look better in a suit than I do in jeans. So there you go. Well, and Paul, without your suit, I wouldn't have my favorite hashtag you do, which is drunk funkel on your Instagram. Thank you. I live for it, Paul. I love your Instagram so much. I want everyone to go follow Paul Feig. And also, Paul, I'm so excited about last Christmas. I am so excited to see it. I can't wait.
而且我穿西装比穿牛仔裤好看。所以就是这样。好吧，保罗，没有你的西装，我就不会有我最喜欢的你在Instagram上的标签，也就是“醉酒的芬克尔”。谢谢。我为它而活，保罗。我非常喜欢你的Instagram。我希望每个人都去关注保罗·费格。而且，保罗，我对《去年圣诞》感到非常兴奋。我非常期待看到它。我等不及了。
Hey. And you know, I loved Game of Thrones. So of course, Jenna doesn't watch Game of Thrones. It drives me crazy. So Amelia Clarke's in it. I'm still an Amelia Clarke fan. Yes. Even though I didn't watch Game of Thrones. So this is very exciting to me. I'm still an Amelia Clarke fan. Yes. Even though I didn't watch Game of Thrones.
嘿。而且你知道，我喜欢《权力的游戏》。所以当然，珍娜不看《权力的游戏》。这让我抓狂。所以艾米莉亚·克拉克在里面。我仍然是艾米莉亚·克拉克的粉丝。是的。即使我没看《权力的游戏》。所以这对我来说非常令人兴奋。我仍然是艾米莉亚·克拉克的粉丝。是的。即使我没看《权力的游戏》。
So this is very exciting to me because I get to see her and not Game of Thrones. Yes, exactly. And then of course, like Emma Thompson, I cannot get enough of that woman. I just live for her. So and Henry Golding and all of it. I can't wait to see it.
所以这对我来说非常令人兴奋，因为我能看到她，而不是《权力的游戏》。是的，完全正确。然后当然，还有艾玛·汤普森，我怎么看那个女人都看不够。我简直为她而活。所以还有亨利·戈尔丁，所有这些。我等不及要看了。
I love, love holiday movies so much. So everybody go see Last Christmas. Yay. We love it. I love, love holiday movies so much. So everybody go see Last Christmas. Oh, thank you. Yay! You'll love it. You'll laugh, you'll cry, and it's one of the most beautiful things I've ever shot. It's just absolutely gorgeous to look at. Oh, I can't wait. I cannot wait to see it. Paul, thank you so much for taking the time to do this. Thank you. Thank you, Paul. Oh, thank you. It's so much fun. I'm so glad you guys are doing this because the show was so special to me. I mean honestly, I just I have to pinch myself that I got to be involved in and be involved with so many
我非常非常喜欢节日电影。所以大家一定要去看《去年圣诞》。耶。我们喜欢它。我非常非常喜欢节日电影。所以大家一定要去看《去年圣诞》。哦，谢谢。耶！你会喜欢的。你会笑，你会哭，这是我拍过的最美丽的东西之一。它看起来绝对华丽。哦，我等不及了。我等不及要看了。保罗，非常感谢你抽出时间来做这件事。谢谢。谢谢，保罗。哦，谢谢。这太有趣了。我很高兴你们在做这件事，因为这个节目对我来说太特别了。我的意思是，老实说，我不得不掐自己一下，因为我能参与其中，并参与了这么多
episodes and so many kind of the bigger ones too and it will just always be one of my proudest proudest moments and working with with you guys was just just one of my great joys. You were just such a wonderful cast to work with. Every day was really fun to come in and just every take was fun and different. And I mean, I just couldn't have had a better time. So thank you for that. And I love you guys very, very much. Oh, Paul. Thank you, Paul.
剧集，还有很多重要的剧集，它将永远是我最引以为豪的时刻之一，与你们一起工作是我最大的快乐之一。你们是一个如此出色的演员阵容。每天来工作都非常有趣，每一条拍摄都很有趣且不同。我的意思是，我不可能有更好的时光了。所以谢谢你们。我非常非常爱你们。哦，保罗。谢谢，保罗。
["The Office Olympics Theme"] Okay, guys, we're back. And now we are going to break down Office Olympics. Yeah. That was so nice talking to Paul. That was so great. All right, let's get into this episode scene by scene. We start with Michael's talking head. He explains that he has come in early and we learned that Ryan had to come in early
["办公室奥运会主题曲"] 好了，伙计们，我们回来了。现在我们要拆解《办公室奥运会》。是的。和保罗聊天真是太好了。那太棒了。好吧，让我们一集一集地进入这一集。我们从迈克尔的采访开始。他解释说他来得很早，我们得知瑞恩不得不来得很早
to bring Michael a sausage, egg and cheese biscuit. Ryan is so pissed. Angela, I noticed a little bit of Ryan's sass. Yeah, Ryan had some sass. Can I get Ryan's sass from you? Yeah. Do you have a card that says Ryan's sass? I don't, because the only person that bumps me with sass is Pam.
给迈克尔带一个香肠、鸡蛋和奶酪饼干。瑞恩气坏了。安吉拉，我注意到了瑞恩的一点傲慢。是的，瑞恩确实有点傲慢。我能从你那里得到瑞恩的傲慢吗？可以。你有一张写着“瑞恩的傲慢”的卡片吗？我没有，因为唯一能用傲慢让我不爽的人是帕姆。
I knew it was targeted. I knew your sass was not universal. I knew it was personal. See, I just proved it. I also remember that Steve had to eat all of those egg and cheese biscuits and he had a bucket under his desk because he would spit them out because remember he had just gotten in this amazing shape and I feel like season one Steve might have enjoyed eating all of those but season two Steve was like
我知道那是针对性的。我知道你的傲慢不是普遍的。我知道那是私人的。看，我刚刚证明了这一点。我还记得史蒂夫必须吃掉所有那些鸡蛋和奶酪饼干，他的桌子下面有一个桶，因为他会把它们吐出来，因为记得他刚刚练出了这种惊人的身材，我觉得第一季的史蒂夫可能很享受吃掉所有那些，但第二季的史蒂夫就像
that I'm not doing that to my body anymore. Also though, I mean, listen, here's the thing. When you have to eat that much food, like the same food over and over, maybe 30 takes of that food, it turns on you. It does. You don't need that sausage egg biscuit turning on you. It's true. I'd spit it out.
那样，我再也不会那样对待我的身体了。不过，我的意思是，听着，事情是这样的。当你必须吃那么多食物时，比如一遍又一遍地吃同样的食物，也许30条拍摄都要吃，它会让你反胃。确实。你不需要那个香肠鸡蛋饼干让你反胃。这是真的。我会把它吐出来。
All right, so then there's another scene that has the thing that I love so much, which is when we start on Michael Speaking to camera and we widen to reveal Dwight lurking over his shoulder It is one of your favorite favorite talking heads and this is when Michael reveals he is buying a condo Going to be a home. Yeah big day for him And then we swoop into the main office and did you notice this Angela? The photo on Jim's desk? I have two note cards about these opening shots in the bullpen.
好吧，那么还有另一个场景，有我非常喜欢的东西，那就是当我们开始拍摄迈克尔对着镜头说话，然后镜头拉宽，露出德怀特在他肩膀后面潜伏。这是你最喜欢的采访之一，这是迈克尔透露他正在买公寓，要成为一个家的时候。是的，对他来说是大日子。然后我们俯冲进入主办公室，你注意到了吗，安吉拉？吉姆桌子上的照片？我有两张关于这些在办公区开场镜头的笔记卡。
At a minute 48 seconds. Do you know what Jim's screensaver is? What? It's a deserted island in the middle of the ocean. I think that's a little foreshadowing to the fire. Which is coming next. Coming next, that desert island. At a minute 51, John's desk
在1分48秒。你知道吉姆的屏幕保护程序是什么吗？什么？是一个在大海中间的荒岛。我觉得那是对火灾的一点预示。接下来要发生的。接下来，那个荒岛。在1分51秒，约翰的桌子
right next to his computer. There's a photo of him holding a baby. Do you know who that is? It's his nephew. It's his nephew. So when we had to personalize our desk, that's one of the things John brought in. He was so proud to be an uncle. I know he's adorable. He was so excited to put that picture on his desk. Then we go to the scene where Jim and Pam are throwing things into Dwight's cup. This is when Pam has to revive Jim because sometimes he dies of boredom. I remember shooting that.
就在他的电脑旁边。有一张他抱着婴儿的照片。你知道那是谁吗？是他侄子。是他侄子。所以当我们必须个性化我们的桌子时，那是约翰带来的东西之一。他为成为叔叔感到非常自豪。我知道他很可爱。他非常兴奋地把那张照片放在他的桌子上。然后我们进入吉姆和帕姆把东西扔进德怀特杯子的场景。这是帕姆必须让吉姆复活的时候，因为有时他会无聊死。我记得拍摄那个场景。
That was really fun. John and I got really into seeing if we really could throw stuff in the cup. Like sometimes that happens where it's in the scene, but then in real life you actually really enjoy it. That was a moment. Well, I have a little something from that scene at two minutes, four seconds, boom!
那真的很有趣。约翰和我真的很投入，看看我们是否真的能把东西扔进杯子里。就像有时场景里会发生这种情况，但在现实生活中你确实很享受它。那是一个时刻。好吧，我从那个场景里有一点东西，在2分4秒，砰！
The boom drops in the scene. Really? The boom operator. Yeah, we got a little bit of boom and they left it in because as you know, it was a mockumentary. So when that happened, they let it stay. They wouldn't let it ruin a take, but there's a boom in that scene. What about Dwight's Mozart, Butch Cassidy talking head?
吊杆麦克风掉进了场景里。真的吗？吊杆操作员。是的，我们有一点吊杆，他们把它留在了里面，因为如你所知，这是一个伪纪录片。所以当这种情况发生时，他们让它留着。他们不会让它毁掉一条拍摄，但那个场景里有一个吊杆。德怀特的莫扎特、布奇·卡西迪采访怎么样？
This to me is such a sign of Mike Schur's writing. I think if you go back and look at every amazing Dwight talking head, most of them were written by Mike Schur. Mike is brilliant. He is brilliant and he's smart. And I mean, I feel like I would wear a t-shirt that says Mozart and Butch Cassidy. You're gonna get a bullet in your head
对我来说，这真是迈克·舒尔写作的标志。我想如果你回去看每一个精彩的德怀特采访，大部分都是迈克·舒尔写的。迈克很天才。他很天才，而且很聪明。我的意思是，我觉得我会穿一件写着“莫扎特和布奇·卡西迪”的T恤。如果你惹莫扎特，大家，你会因为布奇·卡西迪而脑袋挨一颗子弹。我没有惹莫扎特。不。再说一次，迈克尔的杂志列表。他列出了他所有的杂志。他问帕姆是否把《Cracked》和《American Way》杂志转发到了他的新公寓。我只是想指出这一点。他的杂志是《小商人》、《Maxim》、《American Way》、《Cracked》，然后是《艺术》
thanks to Butch Cassidy if you mess with Mozart, everybody. I'm not messing with Mozart. No. Again, Michael's list of magazines. He lists off all his magazines. He asked Pam if she has forwarded, cracked, and American Way magazine to his new condo. I just want to point that out. His magazines are Small Businessman, Maxim, American Way, Cracked, and then the Fine Arts
《鱼与点头月刊》。是的，他编造的那本。是的，那本假杂志。我们在这一集中也第一次看到了迈克尔的车。是第一次吗？我想是的。好吧，在我们要去赛百灵之前，我有一张很大的笔记卡，我想。哦，那你就继续吧。
of Fish and Noddo Monthly. Yeah, the one he made up. Yeah, the fake magazine. We also get to see Michael's car in this episode for the first time. Is it for the first time? I think it is. Well, I have a pretty big note card before we get to the Sebring, I think. Oh, well then go ahead.
赛百灵在几分钟？我不写下分钟。那是你的事。这很奇怪。我喜欢一个好的列表，但你真的对这些分钟很着迷。你知道吗？你和你的排毒可以去死吧，费舍尔。
At what minutes is the Sebring? I don't write down minutes. That's your thing. It's weird. I like a good list, but you're really obsessed with these minutes. You know what? You and your cleanse can suck it, Fisher.
好吧，我那些喜欢背景东西的背景人员。在4分52秒，吉姆正在和奥斯卡说话，奥斯卡的桌子面对着安吉拉和凯文之间的隔板。好的。而在那个隔板上是安吉拉和凯文之间。好的。而在那个隔板上是一张便利贴。那是奥斯卡画的一幅画。在这一集之后，他把它给了我，我仍然留着它。
All right, my background people who love background stuff. At four minutes, 52 seconds, Jim is talking to Oscar and Oscar's desk faces the partition that is between Angela and Kevin. Okay. And on that partition is a between Angela and Kevin. Okay. And on that partition is a post-it note. It's a drawing that Oscar drew. And after this episode, he gave it to me and I still have it.
而且我，所以事情是这样的。它是什么？好的，所以奥斯卡是一个非常好的画家。他非常擅长，他会做这些涂鸦，我保留了很多。他经常会画凯文、安吉拉和奥斯卡，我们的角色在做疯狂的事情。我有一张画，上面是我们骑着轻便摩托车。
And I, so here's the thing. What is it? Okay, so Oscar is a very good drawer. He's very good and he would make these doodles and I kept a lot of them. And he often would draw Kevin, Angela, and Oscar, our characters doing crazy things. I have a drawing of one where we're on a moped.
哦，我见过那一张。那太可爱了。好的，所以这张便利贴是他画的一幅画。这是我个人的最爱之一。那是安吉拉作为施虐者。她正骑在凯文的肩膀上。好的。她手里拿着鞭子，就像她在挥鞭子一样。
Oh, I've seen that one. That's so cute. Okay, so this Post-It note is a drawing he did. It's one of my personal favorites. It is Angela as a dominatrix. She is getting a shoulder ride from Kevin. Okay. She has a whip in her hand, like she's cracking the whip.
而在他们身后被拖着四肢着地的是奥斯卡。哇。是的，这就是他隔板上便利贴上的内容。它让我笑个不停，比如他画的细节，我们的服装，我们的施虐者服装。他画了一个尖刺项圈。他绝对会做所有这些画
And on all fours, being drug behind them, is Oscar by Elish. Wow. Yes, that is what's on the Post-It note on his partition. And it cracks me up, like the detail that he drew, our costumes, our dominatrix costumes. He has like a spike collar on. He definitely would do all these drawings
会计部门的。而我的角色总是以某种方式引发痛苦。但我拥有的最喜欢的东西之一就是这张他画的便利贴。它就在4分52秒的隔板上，我差点从沙发上掉下来。我太兴奋了。但在那之后，他在这一集之后把它给了你
of the accounting department. And my character was always invoking pain in some way. But it is one of my favorite things I own is this Post-it note that he drew. And it's there on the partition at four minutes, 52 seconds, I about fell off my couch. I was so excited. But then after that, he gave it to you after this episode
然后你就再也没在节目中看到它了。它只是为了这一集住在那里。它住在那里。他显然那天画了它并把它贴在那里。我现在拥有它。哦，我喜欢那个。然后还有在4分52秒，因为我们被允许个性化我们的桌子，对吧？
and you would never see it again on the show. It just lived there for this episode. It lived there. He drew it clearly that day and stuck it up there. And I now have it. Oh, I love that. And then also at four minutes 52 seconds, because we were allowed to personalize our desks, right?
有一张奥斯卡带来的他和他的狗在相框里的照片。哦。是的，所以就是这样。我想谈谈迈克尔的车。好的。他有赛百灵敞篷车。我想这是我们第一次真正看到这辆车。
There is a photo that Oscar brought in of himself and his dog in a frame. Oh. Yeah, so there you go. I wanna talk a little bit about Michael's car. Okay. He has the Sebring convertible. I think this is the first time we really see the car.
这当然是我们第一次开这辆车。是的，这是它第一次出镜。而且BJ告诉我，他们非常仔细地挑选了这辆车。他们觉得这是迈克尔在薪水范围内能买得起的最炫的车。它是敞篷车。是的，他非常非常为它自豪。当迈克尔和德怀特离开办公室，他们拍摄那个场景时，兰德尔·艾因霍恩，我们的摄影指导，也是我们的主要摄像师，被塞进了后座，以便获得那些镜头。兰德尔是个大块头，那不是一个大的后座。
It's certainly the first time we drive in the car. It is, the first time it's featured. And BJ told me that they picked this car very carefully. They felt like it was the flashiest car Michael could afford on his salary. It's a convertible. Yes, and he's very, very proud of it. And when Michael and Dwight leave the office and they're shooting that scene, Randall Einhorn, our director of photography and also our main camera operator, was shoved in the back seat in order to get those shots. Randall is a big guy and that is not a big back seat.
不，他告诉我他的膝盖都顶到耳朵边了。他以这种奇怪的姿势扭曲着。我和他交换了一些信息，但他确实说，每当他们必须进入最痛苦的姿势时，他们通常能得到最好的镜头。所以他说，你知道如果你感到疼痛，你就能得到一个很棒的镜头。而且我，赛百灵的后窗在这一集中破了。而且兰德尔在互联网上因此受到指责。真的吗？是的，互联网说兰德尔打破了窗户，它必须被更换。更换它花费了近900美元。我知道，因为，你知道，我们租了这些车。我们没有买它们。
No, he told me that his knees were up by his ears. He was contorted in this weird position. I traded some messages with him and he said, though, that whenever they had to get in the most painful position, they usually got the best shot. So he was like, you knew you were getting a great shot if you were hurting. And I also, the back window of the Sebring broke in this episode. And Randall has been blamed for this on the internet. Really? Yes, the internet says that Randall broke the window and it had to be replaced. It costs almost $900 to replace. I know because, you know, we rented these cars. We didn't buy them.
我问兰德尔这件事，他说，实际上，窗户确实破了。他说，我觉得这很有趣。他说他认为是因为他们把一个摄像机电池组留在了后架上。然后当他们放下敞篷车顶时，它把它压碎了。但他们是谁，兰德尔？他们是谁？那是摄制组吗？
I asked Randall about it and he said, actually, the window did break. He said, this I thought was interesting. He said he thinks it's because they left a camera battery pack on the back shelf. And then when they put the convertible top down, it crunched it. But who's they, Randall? Who is they? Would that be film crew?
那是你吗？摄像机？摄像机？所以他说他们，但是的，它确实在那个场景中破了，然后我们不得不更换它。好的，所以我有一个关于赛百灵的小故事。我有一个时间码。现在我们要跳到前面了，但既然你在谈论它，
Would that be you? Camera? Camera? So he said they, but yes, it did break in that scene and we had to then replace it. Okay, so I have a little story about the Sebring. I have a time code. Now we're jumping ahead, but since you're talking about it,
我要提一下，珍娜。可以吗？我允许。哦，天哪。在16分39秒，有证据表明当时的实际室外温度是多少，因为有一个仪表盘和赛百灵的全景镜头。
I'm gonna bring it up, Jenna. Is that all right? I'll allow it. Oh Lord. At 16 minutes, 39 seconds, there is proof of what the actual outside temperature was because there is a full on camera shot of the dashboard and the Sebring.
上面说他们正在向东行驶，气温是91度。是的，因为我们在仲夏拍摄这一集。在仲夏，我们必须穿上外套假装很冷，但这就是事实。当时是91度。好的，安吉拉，我有一个关于仇恨球的问题。哦，我有一张关于仇恨球的笔记卡。好吧，你的头发。
It says that they are going east and that it is 91 degrees. Yes, because we shot this in the middle of summer. In the middle of summer, we had to have coats on and pretend to be cold, but there you have it. It was 91 degrees. Okay, Angela, I have a question about hate ball. Oh, I have a note card about hate ball. All right, your hair.
是的。在仇恨球里。是的。你能谈谈那个编织发带的东西吗？我一直想谈。好的，所以在5分42秒，有一个通过隔板拍我的很棒的镜头，因为显然我讨厌他们正在做的事情。
Yes. In hate ball. Yes. Will you please talk about the braid headband thing? I have been wanting to. Okay, so at five minutes, 42 seconds, there is a great shot of me through the partition because obviously I hate what they're doing.
所以他们说仇恨球，然后切到我，我正在皱眉。你看到了由我们的发型师金·费里创造的经典发带编织。她在节目中每天都为我做头发。她实际上是一个了不起的编织者。她可以做任何种类的编织，安吉拉·马丁的所有复杂编织和发型都是金·费里做的。所以她称之为发带编织，她会让我做的是，她会把我的头发拉直。好的。她会让我把头翻过来，然后她会从我耳朵的一侧开始
So they say hate ball and they cut to me and I'm frowning. You see the classic headband braid that was created by our hairdresser, Kim Ferry. She did my hair every day on the show. She actually is an amazing braider. She can do any kind of braid and all of my intricate braids and hairstyles of Angela Martin were by Kim Ferry. So she called this the headband braid and what she would have me do is she would flat iron my hair straight. Okay. She would have me flip my head over and then she would start at one side of my ear
做这种像倒置的编织，穿过我的头顶，在耳朵的另一侧结束，让我的头发后面保持直发。所以它只会编织，基本上就像一个发带，穿过我的头顶。它疼吗？它不疼，但我确实必须让我的头保持某种扭曲。
and do this like inverted braid over the top of my head ending at the other side of my ear, leaving the back of my hair straight. So it would only braid like, basically like a headband that went over like the top of my head. Did it hurt? It did not hurt, but I did have to sit with my head kind of contorted.
为了得到这个发型。为了得到它，但这就像我们最喜欢的事情之一，格雷格·丹尼尔斯很喜欢它。他第一次看到它时，他说，哦，天哪，是的，是的，这就是安吉拉·马丁。它后来在很多集中都有出现。我们甚至为NBC.com做了一个幕后花絮，因为很多人问那是不是我的真头发。
In order to get the style. In order to get it, but it was like one of our favorite things, Greg Daniels loved it. The first time he saw it, he was like, oh my God, yes, yes, this is Angela Martin. And it went on to be featured in a lot of episodes. We even did a behind the scenes for NBC.com cause so many people asked if that was my real hair.
那是我的真头发翻过来，倒置编织，它让它看起来像一个发带。发带编织不疼。你宁愿要这个而不是发髻。是的。是的。它就像把你头发的一部分编起来，
It was my real hair flipped upside down, inverted braid, and it made it look like a headband. The headband braid did not hurt. You would far prefer this over a bun. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. It was just like having a part of your hair braided,
但它并不紧，也不会拉扯我的后脑勺。对我来说，那是经典的安吉拉。是的，发带编织。是的。说到头发。是的。在6分15秒，你走到办公室后面，因为他们正在玩邓德球。
but it wasn't tight or pulling at the back of my head. To me, that is classic Angela. Yeah, the headband braid. Yes. Speaking of hair. Yes. At 6 minutes, 15 seconds, you go in the back of the office because they're playing Dunderball.
是的。你看到凯利仍然留着盘发。凯利仍然是盘发。但它有点松。后面有一小块东西垂下来。就像一个松散的编织。它开始掉下来了，珍娜。你知道吗？我想，我要预测一下，因为我们还没有看后面。就像一个松散的编织。它开始掉下来了，珍娜。你知道吗？
Yes. And you see that Kelly still has an updo. Still an updo with Kelly. But it's a little bit looser. There's like a little piece kind of dangling in the back. It's like a loose braid. It's starting to come down, Jenna. You know what? I think, and I'm going to predict, because we have not watched in the back. It's like a loose braid. It's starting to come down, Jenna. You know what?
我想，我要预测一下，因为我们还没有看完所有的剧集。我们确实是按顺序看的。我觉得她的头发在《赌场之夜》掉下来了。我觉得那是她的头发第一次掉下来。我要预测一下。所以让我们看看随着我们继续重看，我是不是对的。因为我知道她的头发在《赌场之夜》是散开的。
I think, and I'm gonna predict, because we have not watched all the episodes. We really are watching them in order. I think her hair comes down in Casino Night. I think it's the first time her hair comes down. I'm gonna predict it. So let's see if I'm right as we continue to rewatch. Cause I know her hair is down in Casino Night.
好吧，我记得。发髻越来越松了。随着我们继续重看。因为我知道她的头发在《赌场之夜》是散开的。好吧。我记得。发髻越来越松了。我们要去那里了，伙计们。很有趣，她的头发散开，吉姆和帕姆越接近接吻，某种程度上。我不知道。什么？那是，你知道吗？毫无意义。
Well, I remember. The bun is getting looser. As we continue to rewatch. Cause I know her hair is down in casino night. Well. I remember. The bun is getting looser. We're heading there folks. It's interesting, it's her hair comes down, the closer Jim and Pam get to kissing, sort of. I don't know. What? That is, you know what? Makes no sense.
你知道那种相关性是什么吗？什么？排毒相关性。哦，不。那是你们的排毒逻辑。那是排毒逻辑。让我们谈谈迈克尔的公寓，拜托。是的。他到了他的公寓，就像我们在“快速事实”中说的那样，房地产经纪人由南希·卡瑞尔扮演。
You know what that correlation is? What? A cleanse correlation. Oh no. That's cleanse logic for you guys. That's cleanse logic. Let us talk about Michael's condo, please. Yes. He gets to his condo and like we said in our Fast Facts, the realtor is played by Nancy
所以我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯向南希推荐了这个角色。她认为南希会很完美。我和艾莉森发了邮件，她说她一直是南希的超级粉丝，她从我们节目的第一天起就在寻找一个适合她的位置，她认为这很完美。她喜欢能够以这种方式让南希和史蒂夫对立起来。迈克·舒尔告诉我，当南希在片场时，史蒂夫非常兴奋。他只是咯咯地笑，很高兴他们在一起太
Carell. So our casting director, Alison Jones, pitched Nancy for this role. She thought Nancy would be perfect. I emailed with Alison and she said that she had always been a huge fan of Nancy's and she was looking from day one on our show to find a place for her and she thought this was perfect. She loved being able to pit Nancy and Steve against one another in this way. Mike Schur told me that Steve was positively giddy when Nancy was on set. He was just giggly and delighted that they're so
可爱了，我们知道他们在一起太可爱了。是的，她很搞笑，也很聪明，但史蒂夫，你想见一个像史蒂夫爱南希那样爱你的男人吗？当然。因为他只是，他只是被她逗乐了。我喜欢迈克尔开始失控的时候，因为他意识到你，你知道，而且德怀特没有帮忙。德怀特就像，你知道，你会75岁。你基本上是在买一口棺材。是的，如果我有一个，如果我买了一口棺材，我会买一个我听不到其他死人声音的。但迈克尔，当他失控时，有这句我喜欢的台词
cute together and we know they're so cute together. Yeah she is hilarious and so smart but Steve you want to meet a man that loves you the way Steve loves Nancy. For sure. Because he just he's just delighted by her. I love when Michael starts to spiral out because he realizes you you know, and Dwight is not helping. Dwight's like, you know, you're gonna be 75. You're basically buying a coffin. Yeah, if I had a, if I bought a coffin, I'd buy one where I couldn't hear the other dead people. But Michael, as he's spiraling, has this line that I love
他说，我被承诺有火辣的人。火辣的人都在哪里？就像什么，在这个公寓开发项目中，你被承诺有火辣的人？但南希对此的反应才是真正让它出彩的地方。安吉拉，你有一张关于公寓的三星卡。好吧，是在6分58秒。这与其说是关于公寓，
where he's like, I was promised hot people. Where are all the hot people? Like what, in this condo development, you were promised hot people? But Nancy's reaction to that is really what makes it. Angela, you have a three-star card about the condo. Well, it's at six minutes 58 seconds. It's not so much about the condo,
不如说是我们在公寓里发现的信息，那就是德怀特有一个60英亩的甜菜农场。是的，这是第一次提到他的甜菜农场。是的，你提到我们看到了莫斯的照片，但这是我们得知德怀特是土地所有者的时候。他有一个工作的甜菜农场。是的，这引出了一个粉丝问题，安吉拉。斯坦写道，在这一集中，德怀特
but it's what information we find out at the condo, which is that Dwight has a 60 acre beet farm. Yes, this is the first mention of his beet farm. Yes, and you mentioned that we see a photo of Moe's, but this is when we learned that Dwight is a landowner. He has a working beet farm. Yes, and this brings up a fan question, Angela. Stan wrote, in this episode, Dwight
说他的父母留给他一个60英亩的甜菜农场，但在第九季的农场里，萨莉阿姨把农场留给了所有三个孩子，如果他们搬回去的话。珍娜，这个差异是因为你偷了节目圣经吗？斯坦，我这里有节目圣经。我指的是节目圣经的第31页。上面说在《办公室奥运会》中，德怀特说他有一个60英亩的工作甜菜农场，是他祖父留给他的。而且，斯坦，如果你想去6分58秒，德怀特有一个对着镜头的采访
says that his parents left him a 60-acre beet farm, but in the farm in season nine, Aunt Sally leaves the farm to all three kids if they move back into it. Jenna, did this discrepancy happen because you stole the show Bible? Stan, I have the show Bible right here. I'm referring to page 31 of the show Bible. And it says that in Office Olympics, Dwight says he has a 60-acre working beet farm left to him by his grandfather. And also, Stan, if you want to go to 6 minutes 58 seconds, Dwight has a talking head to camera
他说，我的祖父母留给我一个60英亩的甜菜农场。是的。所以，斯坦，我不得不说这仍然引出了一个问题，为什么在第九季，我们说那是他的萨莉阿姨拥有甜菜农场？我不知道，我需要重温第九季，因为我知道一个雪莉阿姨，因为她打了我一巴掌，叫我厨房女巫。
where he says, my grandparents left me a 60-acre beet farm. Yeah. So, Stan, I do have to say this still does bring up the question of why in season nine, do we say that it's his aunt Sally who has the beet farm? I don't know, I need to revisit season nine because I know an aunt Shirley, cause she slapped me and called me a kitchen witch.
是的。但我不知道萨莉阿姨是谁。好吧，他有很多亲戚。哦，我知道。伙计们，我确实想说，为了在节目圣经中找到这个参考，我不得不读了大约五页关于德怀特·舒特的真相。而且我认为，如果他们只出版节目圣经的德怀特·舒特部分，它会卖得很好。每一个要点都是金子。随便挑一个读给我们听。好的。来自节目圣经，章节是德怀特。
Yeah. But I don't know who aunt Sally is. Well, he has a number of relatives. Oh, I know. You guys, I do want to say that to find this reference in the show Bible, I had to read something like five pages of facts about Dwight Schrute. And I think that if they only published the Dwight Schrute section of the show Bible, it would do very well. Every single one of these bullet points is gold. Just pick one random one and read it to us. All right. From the show Bible, the chapter is Dwight.
认为狼是对办公室职员的主要威胁。认为狼是对办公室职员的主要威胁。是的，第三季第20集。他说他有一个防空洞。它花了他1200美元。他说那个。他有一个防空洞。它花了他1200美元。他自己做了割礼。不。不。他可以睁着眼睛打喷嚏。这些太棒了。
Thinks wolves are a major threat to office workers. Thanks wolves are a major threat. Yeah, season three, episode 20. He says that he has a bomb shelter. It cost him $1,200. He says that. He has a bomb shelter. It cost him $1,200. He performed his own circumcision. No. No. He can sneeze with his eyes open. These are amazing.
他认为三角龙是最蹩脚的恐龙。我有点想让你做出来。我的意思是，我可以没完没了地说下去。使用鹿鞭作为春药。哦，天哪。可怜的安吉拉·马丁。似乎是摔跤迷。只是假装的。不确定。只是为了面子。
He thinks Triceratops is the lamest dinosaur. I kind of want you to make it. I mean, I could go on and on. Uses deer penis as an aphrodisiac. Oh, god. poor Angela Martin. Appears to be a fan of wrestling. Just fakes it. Not sure. Just for appearances.
这个让我大声笑了出来。他的农场不是有机的。他使用杀虫剂？我想是的。在某一集中，他一定吹嘘过他的农场不是有机的。他有3万美元埋得很深，在某人下面，他不想挖过他们去拿它。
This one made me laugh out loud. His farm is non-organic. He uses pesticides? I guess so. In some episode, he must brag about the fact that his farm is non-organic. He has $30,000 buried very deeply and under someone, and he doesn't want to dig past them to get it.
伙计们，我真的……德怀特……我们要专门做一集，我只给你们读节目圣经里的德怀特·舒特。那太棒了。但是的，6分58秒，巨大的信息，那就是德怀特拥有一个60英亩的甜菜农场。这是他们想出的我最喜欢的事情之一
Guys, I really... The Dwight... We're going to do a whole episode where I just read you Dwight Schrute from the show Bible. That is amazing. But yes, six minutes, 58 seconds, huge information, which is that Dwight owns a 60 acre beet farm. This is one of my favorite things that they came up with
为我们节目中的一个角色，因为我们将永远从这个事实中挖掘金矿。永远。我这里有一张小卡片。在8分36秒，有开幕式。是的。
for a character on our show, because we are just going to continue to mine gold from this fact forever. Forever. I have a little card here. At eight minutes, 36 seconds, there are the opening ceremony. Yes.
有一个横幅，有点燃蜡烛。我想为你们分享一个小幕后故事。所以每当我们有点燃的蜡烛时，我们必须依法进行安全会议。我过去常常笑个不停，因为我会想到那些有汽车追逐和爆炸之类的节目。
There's a banner, there's the lighting of a candle. I wanted to share a little behind the scenes story for you guys. So whenever we had a lit candle, we had to by law have a safety meeting. And I used to crack up, because I would think about shows that had car chases and explosives and things.
而在我们的节目中，你必须为点燃蜡烛进行安全会议。而我们的节目，你必须为点燃蜡烛进行安全会议。我们的第二助理导演，凯利·坎特利，会说，安全会议，我们将有一支点燃的蜡烛。是的，那是真正的火，每个人，在片场。请注意蜡烛周围的袖子和手肘。一支点燃的蜡烛，每个人。
And on our show, you had a safety meeting about a candle being lit. And our our show, you had a safety meeting about a candle being lit. And our second AD, Kelly Cantley, would go, safety meeting, we will have a lit candle. Yes, that is real fire, everyone, on the set. Please be aware of your sleeves and elbows around the candle. A lit candle, everyone.
好的，安全会议休会。很有趣，因为我后来去做的节目或项目，我们会有安全会议，他们会用那种同样的虚张声势说出来，但他们实际上会像，每个人注意。一辆车将在两点钟爆炸。是的。所以请保持距离，车爆炸后不要靠近它，因为它会是
Okay, safety meeting adjourned. And it's funny because I would go on to do shows or projects where we would have safety meetings and they would be said with sort of that same bravado, but they would really be like, everyone pay attention. A car will be exploding at two o'clock. Yeah. So please keep your distance, do not go toward the car after it has exploded as it will be
好了，安全会议到此结束。有趣的是，后来我参与的一些节目或项目中也会开安全会议，大家说话时也带着那种虚张声势的劲头，但实际上他们是想说，大家注意了，两点钟方向会有一辆车爆炸。所以请保持距离，车爆炸后千万不要靠近，因为它会
hot. But on our show it was- We will have one candle. It will be lit with a lighter. A very long lighter too. A very long lighter to protect John's hands. Safety meeting. I wanna say in that same scene with the opening ceremonies, I really drew the sign that says
热。但在我们的节目里，我们会有一根蜡烛。它会用打火机点燃。还是一个很长的打火机。一个很长的打火机是为了保护约翰的手。安全会议。我想说在开幕式的那一幕里，我真的画了那个写着
Games of the first Dunder Mifflin Olympiad. You drew that? I drew it. Did you color it in? Yes. You made the sign. Yes. What the hell, really?
第一届邓德·米夫林奥林匹克运动会。那是你画的？是我画的。你给它上色了吗？是的。你做了那个牌子。是的。天哪，真的吗？
I made it. Those are my bubble letters. I drew it. I also put together a lot of the yogurt lid things. I did it as part of... Your method acting? No, it's not part of my method acting. They gave me some paper clips and yogurt lids and they had some shots of me putting together the medals at my desk. We never used it, but I did do it. And then I also made that sign myself. Now, did they want you to make that sign? I don't remember.
是我做的。那是我的泡泡字体。是我画的。我还把很多酸奶盖拼在一起。我做这个是作为……你的体验派表演的一部分？不，这不是我体验派表演的一部分。他们给了我一些回形针和酸奶盖，还拍了一些我在办公桌前制作奖牌的镜头。我们从没用过，但我确实做了。然后我还自己做了那个牌子。那么，他们让你做那个牌子了吗？我不记得了。
Or did you volunteer in your method acting ways? You know, I feel like Phil Shea came up to me and said, do you want to make the sign since Pam made it? And I said, sure, why not? There were times where they would ask me, you know, Angela, your character is going to hand this piece of paper do you want to write out all the things so it's in your handwriting and we always did we always would sort of do that kind of thing. I liked that detail. Continuing our conversation about the Office Olympics we should talk about the game Flonkerton. Yes we should. I got a lot of questions. People asked, was Flunkerton scripted or improved? It was a written line, but I was told to deliver it like I was making it up on the spot.
还是你以体验派表演的方式主动请缨的？你知道，我觉得菲尔·谢伊走过来对我说，既然帕姆做了那个牌子，你想做吗？我说，当然，为什么不呢？有时候他们会问我，你知道，安吉拉，你的角色要递这张纸，你想把上面的内容写出来吗，这样就是你的笔迹了，我们总是会做那种事。我喜欢那个细节。继续我们关于办公室奥运会的话题，我们应该谈谈“弗隆克顿”这个游戏。是的，我们应该谈谈。我收到了很多问题。人们问，弗隆克顿是写在剧本里的还是即兴发挥的？那是剧本里的台词，但我被告知要表现得像是我当场编出来的一样。
Yes, that was scripted. A lot of people also asked who came up with the term Flunkerton. It was Mike Schur. Well, Mike said it was either him or Greg Daniels, but he is personally obsessed with the FL sound, the fluh. The fluh sound. He thinks it's very funny. He said that is also how Toby got his last name Flunderson, that Mike was responsible for that. So he's pretty sure he can claim having written Flonkerton. I remember Phyllis had so much fun doing that scene. She had so much fun. Phyllis loves getting to play basketball, play
是的，那是剧本写的。很多人还问是谁想出了“弗隆克顿”这个词。是迈克·舒尔。嗯，迈克说要么是他，要么是格雷格·丹尼尔斯，但他个人对“FL”这个音非常着迷，就是“fluh”这个音。那个“fluh”音。他觉得这很有趣。他说这也是托比的姓氏“弗伦德森”的由来，迈克对此负责。所以他很确定他可以声称自己写了“弗隆克顿”。我记得菲利斯在拍那场戏时玩得很开心。她玩得太开心了。菲利斯喜欢打篮球，玩
Flonkerton. To play games. She wants to be a participant. She was very excited. I felt like Jenna, I have two note cards here that I felt like we should outline a little bit of the games. Let's do it. Okay. First of all, there are the games that people played that weren't part of the office Olympics, but were the inspiration for Jim when he was going around to everyone's like sort's desk area. So Pam, of course, threw things into Dwight's coffee cup.
弗隆克顿。玩游戏。她想成为参与者。她非常兴奋。我觉得珍娜，我这里有两张笔记卡，我觉得我们应该列出一些游戏的大纲。我们开始吧。好的。首先，有些游戏是人们玩的，它们不是办公室奥运会的一部分，但却是吉姆在办公桌区域转悠时的灵感来源。所以帕姆，当然，把东西扔进了德怀特的咖啡杯里。
There was hate ball and accounting. There was Dunderball and human resources. Stanley said he plays work hard so his kids can go to college. And then Angela Martin says she plays Pampong. Yeah. Yeah. Oh. That's some Angela sass.
会计部有“恨球”。人力资源部有“邓德球”。斯坦利说他努力工作是为了让他的孩子能上大学。然后安吉拉·马丁说她玩“帕姆乒乓”。是的。是的。哦。那是安吉拉的毒舌。
That is some serious Angela sass. I have a question for you about Pam Pong. Okay. Is this the first time that an office coworker has called out the Jim Pam crush? Yes. Right? That's the first time someone's like, oh, I see what's happening. You're not fooling anyone. Yes. Right? That's the first time someone's like, oh, I see what's happening. You're not fooling anyone.
那真是相当毒舌。我有一个关于“帕姆乒乓”的问题要问你。好的。这是第一次有办公室同事点破吉姆和帕姆之间的暧昧吗？是的，对吧？这是第一次有人说，哦，我看出发生了什么。你骗不了任何人。是的，对吧？这是第一次有人说，哦，我看出发生了什么。你骗不了任何人。
Yes. Yeah. Yeah, and Pam is super self-conscious about it for the rest of the episode. Yeah. And then, of course, we have Angela at 16 minutes, 20 seconds. She's keeping score.
是的。是的，是的，帕姆在这一集的剩余时间里对此感到非常不自在。是的。然后，当然，我们在16分20秒时看到了安吉拉。她在记分。
She comes over. That's the only game she's playing that day. That's the only game she's playing. But then the actual games that Jim makes up, Jim and Pam, right? They make these up. Our number one, Flunkerton, Phyllis being the winner of that. Number two, how many M&Ms can you put in your mouth? Kevin was the only- Only participant.
她走过来。那是她那天玩的唯一一个游戏。那是她玩的唯一一个游戏。但吉姆发明的实际游戏，吉姆和帕姆，对吧？他们发明了这些。第一名，弗隆克顿，菲利斯是赢家。第二名，你能往嘴里塞多少颗M&M豆？凯文是唯一的——唯一的参与者。
Only participant. Three, Guess the Elevator. Inspired by the Real Office Olympics. And Ryan won that. And then the final game that we see is this full coffee mug relay between Oscar and Toby. And it disrupts when Michael and Dwight come in the office and we never see the outcome of that. Well, we kind of do. I think Toby's coffee is spilling at the end. So you're-
唯一的参与者。第三，猜电梯。灵感来自真实的办公室奥运会。瑞安赢了。然后我们看到的最后一个游戏是奥斯卡和托比之间的咖啡杯接力赛。当迈克尔和德怀特走进办公室时，它被打断了，我们从未看到结果。嗯，我们算是看到了。我想托比的咖啡在最后洒了。所以你——
I'm giving it to Oscar. You're giving it to Oscar? Okay, okay. But you have two medals hanging on your desk at 17 minutes, 32 seconds. You have a gold and a silver. Yeah. So I wonder what Pam won for. I don't know. You're saying I don't deserve my medals, Angela? No, Clint. I'm not. I'm just merely being a fan saying I wonder what other games we didn't get to
我把票投给奥斯卡。你投给奥斯卡？好吧，好吧。但在17分32秒时，你的桌子上挂着两枚奖牌。你有一枚金牌和一枚银牌。是的。所以我很好奇帕姆赢了什么。我不知道。你是说我不配得到我的奖牌吗，安吉拉？不，克林特。我不是那个意思。我只是作为一个粉丝说，我很好奇还有什么游戏我们没能
see. Yeah. Well, obviously something where Pam won a gold medal. Oh my God, sass. Just wanna say. Okay. All right, Angela. Maybe she won a gold medal at Pam Pong. I, oh, I see. I see what you've done there. Thank you. I do have a fan question. Karen asked, did you get to take home the medals?
看到。是的。好吧，显然是帕姆赢了金牌的游戏。天哪，真毒舌。只想说。好吧。好的，安吉拉。也许她在“帕姆乒乓”里赢了金牌。哦，我明白了。我明白你的意思了。谢谢。我确实有一个粉丝问题。凯伦问，你们能把奖牌带回家吗？
Yes, and I still have mine. Aw. I have a yogurt lid medal in my home office and it is hanging on my dundee. And from this episode, I have the drawing Oscar did of Angela as a dominatrix pulling Kevin and Oscar around in costume. We kept all kinds of stuff from the show.
是的，我现在还留着我的。啊。我的家庭办公室里有一个酸奶盖奖牌，它挂在我的邓迪奖杯上。从这一集里，我还留着奥斯卡画的那幅画，画的是安吉拉作为女王调教着凯文和奥斯卡。我们留下了各种各样的剧组物品。
We did, we're a little bit of hoarders guys. Someday we joke that we're gonna do a book and put them all somewhere where we can share them. I think we should. I think we should too. We should go through our bins and we should share all this memorabilia and our tons of photos. I mean we have so many. So many.
我们确实留下了，我们有点像囤积狂，伙计们。我们开玩笑说，总有一天我们要出一本书，把它们放在我们可以分享的地方。我觉得我们应该这样做。我也觉得我们应该这样做。我们应该翻翻我们的箱子，分享所有这些纪念品和我们成吨的照片。我是说我们有很多。非常多。
Can we finally get on that please, Angela? Can we do that? Yes. You guys would want that, right? You would want a book of this stuff. Do people want that? Like a scrapbook. A scrapbook. Like our sort of BFF scrapbook. Yeah. Yeah. I think we should because I want to do it before I lose the stuff. Okay.
我们能终于开始做这件事了吗，安吉拉？我们能做吗？是的。你们会想看吧，对吧？你们会想要一本关于这些东西的书。人们想要吗？就像剪贴簿一样。剪贴簿。就像我们那种闺蜜剪贴簿。是的。是的。我觉得我们应该做，因为我想在弄丢这些东西之前把它做出来。好的。
Because I'm worried. I'm worried about my shed. Lastly, guys, I cannot not talk about the scene at 20 minutes, 53 seconds. It's the closing ceremonies. And we talked a little bit about this with Paul. And I agree. Steve did such an amazing performance where as Michael, he tears up. He's made this huge life choice to buy a condo. He's feeling this love and support from his office family that he doesn't get from his family probably. The office family is his family and he's absolutely emotional. And when we filmed it, we did not know that Steve was gonna make that choice to get emotional.
因为我很担心。我担心我的棚屋。最后，伙计们，我不能不谈谈20分53秒的那场戏。那是闭幕式。我们和保罗谈过一点这个。我同意。史蒂夫的表演太棒了，作为迈克尔，他流泪了。他做出了买公寓这个重大的人生选择。他感受到了来自办公室家人的爱和支持，这可能是他在自己家里得不到的。办公室家人就是他的家人，他完全动情了。当我们拍摄时，我们不知道史蒂夫会做出动情的选择。
And so we're all looking at him and he started to tear up. And I, as Angela Martin started, as myself, started to tear up. It was so moving, just sort of his honest portrayal of this person. And Steve is just amazing. Yeah. When that happened in the first take that that happened in, Paul then said to us, this
所以我们都在看着他，他开始流泪了。而我，作为安吉拉·马丁，作为我自己，也开始流泪了。这太感人了，他对他所扮演的这个人的真实刻画。史蒂夫真是太棒了。是的。当第一次拍摄发生这种情况时，保罗对我们说，这
is the direction of this scene. This is how we're going to do it. So everyone just be proud of Michael. Just play it real. Play it real. It was hard for me because I feel like Angela Martin did not want to participate in Office Olympics, probably thought this was a waste of time. Also probably doesn't have really a lot of warm feelings
就是这场戏的基调。我们要这样演。所以每个人都要为迈克尔感到骄傲。只要表现得真实。表现得真实。这对我来说很难，因为我觉得安吉拉·马丁不想参加办公室奥运会，可能觉得这是在浪费时间。而且可能对迈克尔也没有太多温暖的感觉
towards Michael. But for me as Angela Kinsey, watching my friend Steve do this performance, it was so hard not to get emotional and sort of know the fine line that was me reacting and Angela Martin, how she would react. I teared up when we shot this. I tear up every time I watch it.
但对我安吉拉·金赛来说，看着我的朋友史蒂夫进行这样的表演，很难不被感动，也很难把握我作为安吉拉·金赛的反应和安吉拉·马丁会有的反应之间的界限。我们拍这场戏时我流泪了。每次看的时候我都会流泪。
I also watched this episode three times in preparation for this podcast and I cried every time. Yeah, Isabel, when she watched it with me, she said, mommy, he's crying. I said, I know, I know. It was a big moment in his life. These are the things I love about this show. Same.
为了准备这个播客，我也看了三遍这一集，每次我都哭了。是的，伊莎贝尔和我一起看的时候，她说，妈妈，他在哭。我说，我知道，我知道。这是他生命中的一个重要时刻。这些就是我喜欢这部剧的地方。我也是。
Guys, that's Office Olympics. That is Office Olympics. Join us next week for The Fire. Yes. You're gonna hear all about how Angela was almost carried away by a giant bug. And I might've hit John Krasinski. You did hit John Krasinski.
伙计们，这就是办公室奥运会。这就是办公室奥运会。下周加入我们，一起聊聊“火灾”那一集。是的。你们会听到安吉拉差点被一只巨大的虫子带走的故事。而且我可能打了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。你确实打了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。
All right, we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。